e
to
Edna I'm opening the public hearing on
House Bill 144 in call the prime sponsor
representative groa thank you chair
Maguire I'm Jackie groa I'm the state
representative Rockingham District 24
and I'm introducing House Bill 144 at
the request of the board of dental
examiners when they were reviewing their
rule making versus statute they found a
deficiency in that the rule
making allows hygienist to use nitrous
oxide and local
anesthesia but it doesn't in the um stat
you give them that Authority and it also
doesn't um give any requirements for
that so this bill is really just a bill
that marriages Ru making and statute
efficiency okay thank you very much are
there any questions by the
you all right is there anyone else who
144 represent yeah if you don't
representative Gro where' you go uh I
guess I'm just
I didn't quite follow that
uh but it's early so it's it's later
than you it's later than you think the
they weren't doing Stu the rules were
deficient they wanted they weren't doing
stuff beyond their scope were were they
is that the implication
here no they were not doing things
beyond their scope but the fact that let
me read you the exact thing the
administration of nitrous okay the board
found a discrepancy between hygienists
who administer nitrous oxide and those
who administer local anesthesia the
statute requires special education and
examination to obtain a permit to
administer nitrous oxide but the statute
appears to include the administration of
local anesthesia and the practice of
dental hygienist without any further
so you want you want this additional
education there's a certain amount of
training that they have and that they
should have and they want to put that in
statute yes okay all
right okay any other question pitech the
other question I have isn't for you does
anybody still use nitrous
oxide I have no idea I don't i' like to
hear if somebody's somebody's nodding
their head in the back so I think it's
possible
representative thank you representative
Pearson
that's turn the button on turn the M for
the mic thank you sorry good morning my
name is Lori Rosado I'm a practicing
dentist here in um conquer and I'm the
uh Council for governmental Affairs for
New Hampshire Dental society's um well
chair yes nitrous oxide is used in New
Hampshire it's used everywhere um mostly
in sedation settings obviously like an
oral surgeon's office but many general
dentist office still use it safely okay
and to what representative Gro was
saying um the this is already being
practiced by hygienist as a profession
practice safely and within their scope
they just want to make the rule
statute this is a board request okay
thank you any other questions or L um
thank you madam chair and thank you um
it sounds like what we're doing is
making sure that the board can ensure
that they are qualified to do what
they're doing because right now the
statute says they can do it but there's
no qualifications is that correct I'm
not I just want to be clear that I'm not
here on behalf of the board but yes
that's how I read it thank you thank you
all right is there anyone else who
hearing
rep representative BR you have a motion
yes I move a to pass on House Bill
144 second okay we should go into
executive session oh yes thank you we're
going into executive session did a
minute
motion no um I I I can just say that
this is at the request of the board of
dental hygienist to make that to um put
into statute what they have in Ru making
okay repr land do you to speak to your
second uh yes this seems to increase the
protection for patients by having the
practice actually being held to
standards put into law and um I'm
looking forward to this passing okay is
there any U anyone else comments
questions concerns representative
please hit the button but it didn't work
you know how technology is in old people
anyway
um so uh the the important aspect here
that was briefly alluded to but uh it
needs to be in all our Consciousness is
that they have to be
examined uh to demonstrate that they've
had the training and that they're
proficient in the application so um
That's the basis for the board to
require that thank
you anyone else
representers thank you madam chair so I
have a question to the have we had a
problem in this area where H H no okay
as far as I know there was an audit of
the uh Dental Board two or three years
ago and it pointed out there were a
number of discrepancies between the
rules and the statute and this is just
one case of fixing that
discrepancy as far as I know one follow
follow up
so I it just seems like we're I I
licensing and and that aspect of things
it seems like we're adding we keep
adding and adding where I
know Governor spu previously was trying
to get rid of rid of so I'm just curious
yeah but I don't think we're going to
repeal the license for dental
hygienists and if we're continuing to
license them this is to re um require
them to be trained which you're right it
does seem redundant and not necessary so
feel free to vote against the bill it's
it it's keeping the paperwork straight
and that's about all it's
right the motion is ought to pass by
representative broa and the clerk can
Vice chairman Leon
yes clerk votes yes representative
Pearson
yes representative Bailey
I
repres representative
sers
yes representative groda
yes representative Schmidt yes
representative Davis
yes representative Howard
yes and the chair
yes two four 6 8 10 12 nothing 12 Z move
consent okay there any objections to
consent seeing none we'll put that on
consent pres BR if you could at your
convenience
and I don't think we have is there any
other bill that someone thinks we could
exec at the moment or we should discuss
guess
not
okay all right in that
case thank you all that we are in recess
I
e
good morning welcome back to Edna I'm
opening the public hearing on House Bill
145 and I call Representative broa
thank you chair McGuire my name is
Jackie groa I represent the Rockingham
District 24 the towns of Ryan Greenland
and I'm here to introduce House Bill 145
which is a social compact for dieticians
I mean a compact for dieticians excuse
me um compacts
are a originally were designed by the
department of educ of um defense to help
um portability between spouses who had a
specific
profession and the idea of a compact is
that states get together describe what
the um requirements will be for a lure
and then anyone
who um lives in that state and meets the
requirements of lure can practice in the
states where the compacts are held the
board of dieticians are quite
enthusiastic about joining a compact for
their profession and I I um offer to
sponsor their bill and I'm sure you'll
have questions about that and I will
allow I will let them answer those
questions I think they should be the
ones that um promote
the bill
itself thank you represent scitech for
the record was this a request yes
questions okay in that case I will call
board thank you and good morning my name
is Abby svard I am registered dietitian
and current chair of the board of
licensed dietitians I am here
representing the board and providing
information surrounding HB
145 I wanted to briefly discuss the role
that dietitians play in the state of New
Hampshire as we are all likely aware
nutrition is present in our lives every
single day and the sources of
information that exist through news and
media in particular continue to make it
difficult to differentiate what is true
and what are myths and falsities in the
world of food and
nutrition there are often less qualified
individuals providing nutrition
information and education to the public
with li limited evidence-based backing
our rsas specifically 326 H2 speak to
the understanding of the value and the
role that dietitians play in treating
illness injury in other medical
conditions and improving the overall
quality of
life it also speaks upon the
understanding that we cannot restrict
any any person's ability to provide
advice or Counseling in the matter of
food diet and nutrition but rather
establish regulations and standards of
qualification training and experience
for those who are practicing registered
dietitians to ensure the safety of the
public as chair of the board I recognize
the importance and value the board holds
in the state in upholding these
values the compact is governed by a
separate entity however given the
privilege to practice model and within
the compact language those who reside in
the state of New Hampshire as their home
state will continue to follow
appropriate protocols to obtain and
maintain lure according to succinct
guidelines and under our established
rsas this ensures that those who reside
and are practicing in the state are
qualified maintaining required
continuing education credits and
continue to prioritize serving the
public safely and
responsibly aside from the criminal
history check that is included within
this bill
New Hampshire licensing requirements
align with the terms and provisions of
the
compact lienes can choose to hold a
single state license or obtain a compact
license supporting individual
autonomy they also have the choice for
having the opinion or the option for
portability within their
license within the compact language
member states of the compact shall
retain sole jurisdiction over the
provision of single state licensure
currently background checks to obtain
dietician lure in the state are not
required but HB 145 adds the requirement
for a criminal history check upon
obtaining initial
lure this will provide more assurance
that those residing in the state of New
Hampshire are committed to Safe
practices with a unified compact
commission's data system we will have
the information and resources to
identify those who have compact
privileges in the state in all
jurisdictions will be made aware if
there are any allegations or misconduct
specifically relating to investigations
or and or complaints of a
ly essentially this provides information
exchange within compact States so if
there's something that can impact
somebody's ability to practice states
are made aware with the goal to support
Public
Safety the compact language also ensures
that lenses exercising a compact
privilege shall adhere to the laws and
regulations of remote
States thank you committee I know we
have a lot of really great attendance to
be able to testify for this so I'm going
to leave it at that and welcome to any
questions I w't take up too much
additional time thank
you representative Pearson thank you
madam chair um just be before we all
start with questions are you well well
read on this compact are you the person
to ask questions about the
compact I am I think there are also some
others in this room that are very well
qualified so I will most definitely do
my best to answer the questions if
there's any takeaways that I need to get
back back to you with I absolutely will
have a couple but we'll start with this
um and I know this seems like we're
we're running the credits before we're
watching the movie um but being familiar
with other compacts that the state has
entered into what is the procedure to
get out of this
compact if if this compact ends up not
working out for us so I believe there's
an opportunity to withdraw from the
compact um we would have it would take
place I think 180 days from initiation
of that
withdrawal where is that defined
at uh it's in section section 12 of the
any other questions or represent than
you pearon uh the the only other
question I have um that's
that's bouncing off the top of my head
you made a mention of state license or
compact license that is something that I
have not heard before when we as far as
entering into compacts can you elaborate
how that works because it sounds like
you're asking for two LIC different
types of
license yeah so my understanding is that
there's two different models of compacts
um one is a multi-state model so you get
a license in a home state and then you
can practice in any other compact state
so this compact is a privilege to
practice model meaning that you have to
maintain and obtain a home state lure
and then you would have to apply to the
governing body to obtain that compact
state okay followup then follow please
um yeah okay
so this would allow you then to have a
state of New Hampshire license but not
necessarily if you have no desire to
work in Vermont or Maine or whatever and
you just want to work in New
Hampshire
then there's you just kind of stop at a
certain point and don't have to continue
on in order to get a compact license
correct you have the autonomy to decide
if you want a single state licensure or
if you want to enter the compact that
allows you to practice in multiple
States in that case you would apply to
that state for their compact license
it's a much easier process there is
still a fee involved so there is still
that but it's um a much more reduced fee
it makes the process much easier and as
long as you're maintaining credentials
in your home state then you don't have
to abide by every single State's CU
requirements and go above and beyond for
all of those other additional
requirements it makes the process a lot
more simple to give the privilege to
practice in other states okay thank you
thank you you're welcome thank you for
the questionative Le on and then SL uh
thank you madam chair and thank you for
being here um is the criminal records
check something that's being added so
that our laws are in line with this
compact or is that a separate issue
thank you for the question and you are
correct that is the reason why it is
added in it aligns with a compact
language so it would be required I
follow it um and um also has this been
adopted by other enough other states
that it's in force um and if so have
there been any changes because I see
that if there was anything that needed
to be changed every single state who's
part of it would need to CH adapt that
change in their law before it's
effective yeah thank you so much for
that question um so as of right now four
states have legislation enacted we need
seven in order for it to be an acting
compact I believe in the moment we have
10 states that's including New Hampshire
as well that have legislation pending so
to answer your question there's still
room to be able to make modific ations
because the compact is not quite yet en
acting compact but there are four states
that have legislation enacted if I can
have one more follow follow thank you
and um my other question is just around
the need for the criminal background
check my understanding is a lot of the
Your Role is in health care settings
where you're not in one-on-one
situations with vulnerable people and
I'm trying to understand why you would
need to have a criminal background check
in order to do the valuable work you do
that is a wonderful question and I I'm
going to have to I would have to take
that away I don't know the reason and
the ideology for why that would have
been presented within the compact
language in particular so without saying
specifics I would if you're okay with it
take that back and get back to you via
email with that appreciate that thank
you of course you're
welcome representative sitech uh I'm
following up on representative lon's uh
if I if I Forge checks what's that have
to do with my ab ability to be a
licensed dietician my question really is
what is the impact what's the
consequence they do a background check
and then what what how is
that uh information
used the if I may follow a separate
question regardless of this reciprocity
still exists I could decline I could get
a single state license or New Hampshire
license and apply for reciprocity to
Massachusetts regardless of the compact
is that not
true correct so to answer the secondary
question um you can still apply for
reciprocity but when you do you're still
going to have to maintain the
credentials within that state so it may
be easy to get a reciprocal license but
then moving forward you're still going
to have to maintain all the credentials
within that state and that can be really
difficult for a lot of people you know
um whether it be the cost or you know
just maintaining the the continuing
educations within that state but just
from a factual perspective um you are
correct they could have a reciprocal
license and New Hampshire does honor
that and the first question and the
first question again what what's the
impact what what happens after as a
result of the criminal background check
yeah and that is another question I
guess my privity with the background
check and the outcomes I would want to
take that away my understanding is that
states can use that to decide whether
they want a a leny to be licensed um but
I don't know the qualifications in
particular for what would differentiate
okay that's okay and that's not as far
as like an ethical perspective so I
can't unfortunately I'm not going to
speak on that I would want to take that
away to get you a more accurate and
appropriate answer and there may be
others that can speak on that um
generally for most professions if it's a
clean background check the it just sails
through if there are any flaws the board
has to decide what's what's relevant and
what's not thank you I think not having
this within ourly since you're currently
just makes it a little bit of a barrier
for me to speak
on okay any other questions all right
thank you we will be grilling the next
thank you madam chair uh ladies and
gentlemen of the committee for the
record my name is Kevin Grady I a 25y
year Air Force veteran and I'm a 27-year
resident of the town of hooks at New
Hampshire uh today I'm here representing
the uh the 20 members of the state
veterans advisory committee and we're
chartered by state
RSA 115 colon a-8 if you want to look us
up you can also find us through the the
department of military Affairs and
veteran services website where we a sort
of a link to there as well we're made up
of 20 member organizations to kind of
speak for what veterans are thinking in
the State uh these names should be
familiar with you places like
organizations like the American Legion
the Veterans of Foreign Wars I per I
personally represent the Aon space
forces Association uh on the committee
and I'm also their legislative chair
which means that I go through all of the
bills that are being proposed and we
take we find the ones that have veteran
impact we think and we take a position
on those bills and then I come and I
tell you what those what our position is
on that this bill was not on my radar
initially and then they pointed out
section six which is three lines about
the uh about military and Military
spouses uh being involved in part of
this um we like to tell people when I
come up and talk to people that in our
mind when one of us serves the entire
family serves so anything that we can do
especially for military spouses to make
their job easier to make their
transition easier as they go from place
to place particularly those with
professional credentials we're all for
it I also caution folks when I come up
and talk to him that that our committee
is not
necessarily the experts on all the nuts
and bolts of how all of this stuff works
so what I'm here to tell you today is
that we support the concept of military
families uh being involved with this
where it's a good thing with we support
the concept of reciprocity across state
lines of professional credential as our
families move around the nuts and bolts
of how we get there I leave to people
who are better qualified than me to
answer that so within the other the last
thing I want to leave you with is if
you're planning to introduce a bill that
you think has veteran impact we're a
resource that you can use we'd be happy
to look at the language if it's been
tried before and there was a reason why
it didn't really gain any traction In
The House of the Senate we can tell you
that and we can also help you get the
language right so that a year down the
road we don't have to look at
potentially an unintended consequence of
this that we have to go and revise the
rsas for it so um with that I I'll
conclude my testimony if you have any
questions for me I'll be happy to answer
them for the committee the section he's
talking about is on page seven lines 30
to
33 and it looks pretty straightforward
to me but are there any questions
representive
Schmid thank you madam chair well as a
former member of the Armed Forces myself
many years ago uh I know what it's like
to serve I also know what it's like to
have problems with uh the food that's
provided uh because in many cases uh the
people doing the doing the stirring and
the serving and so forth uh are there
for they're they're ordered to to do mes
Duty we called it in the Marine Corps uh
and and sometimes I think they have um
had some slip UPS because uh it was not
infrequent that we would have problems
with the food that led to some issues uh
so I I'm in favor of having people who
are well qualified but but my question
to you is um uh and we've seen this
repeatedly in this committee those of us
who served for a while uh the fact is
veterans get moved around a lot um
you're you're this Duty station and six
months later or someplace all the way
across the country so the idea of people
who are have a background the kind of
training that we're looking for in New
Hampshire um they may be coming in from
some other state where they've served
and so forth and they qualified and the
idea of a compact would be to their
benefit we've we've do done that with a
number of profess sessions where we
recognize the training service they've
had in the military when they come to
New Hampshire so is this something
you're that you're going to look at and
and can you speak to that well we're
we're certainly in favor of of all of
those measures and there's been a few of
them in the last few years that have
have worked to make this process easier
the other thing that we always talk
about is is that at some point you're
not going to be in the military anymore
and then you're going to have to figure
out where it is you want to go and if
we're a state where it's relatively easy
for your your your spouse who is
professionally credentialed to get
credentialed right off the bat when you
get there that might be a consideration
when you decide where you're going to
you and for the committee's information
if some if a dietician comes in from
another state the only technical
qualification for a license by
endorsement is to have passed the
registered dietician test which I
believe is commonly used by almost every
state there's no other technical
requirement there's of course the form
and the fee but that's that's normal
representative of the chair are you
saying that I don't know that the armed
services have licensed the dietitians
but you're saying in effect I believe
that a dietician in good standing
leaving the military if they can p if
that person can pass the test that
you've just alluded to that you just
referenced
they they can be a member of this
compact no no I'm saying that currently
if a a dietician Moves In from another
state which state requires passing this
test to get the license they're eligible
for a license by endorsement after
basically filling in the form and
sending a
check um there's no not very many
honorous requirements on getting a New
Hampshire license if you have another
stes license and the board the the
department of military and Veterans
Affairs is working with oplc to get the
um codes if there are in fact dietitians
in the military what codes would apply
toward this lure so it's not yet I I
don't know the status of it my
understanding is that this work has been
ongoing for a year or so now we had a
bill last year to try and take military
o uh occupational Specialties and Air
Force specialty codes and by code work
out what professional licensing uh
things they might apply might uh qualify
for in the state of New Hampshire and as
I understand it that work is still
ongoing between DMS and oplc the um the
oplc in their uh orientation
presentation said that they are working
on it they've done a couple of boards
but they are nowhere they're finished I
have no idea if the military employe
dietitians but it certainly would apply
to
spouses representative Schmidt thank you
mam chair well this Co colloquy we've
been having reminds me of the fact that
ordinarily we would see be seeing Warren
Perry uh in Committee in engaging on
these types of subjects but we had one a
couple of days ago when he wasn't there
and he's not there this morning I'm
wondering uh is has he retired or and if
so who is replacing him yes sir he has
retired he retired in December he has a
brand new grand baby and he's decided
he's going to go fishing and uh a a a
better public servant uh to the state of
New Hampshire than Warren Perry you you
probably couldn't find anywhere great
man he's been replaced by uh a retired
Air Force Colonel by the name of Nicole
Des
Bixler and you may see her she's across
the way testifying at a Senate bill
right now otherwise she would be here so
we'll look forward to seeing her because
uh that very helpful Warren was so
experienced that he could really help us
thank you represent so we look forward
to seeing Nicole shortly are there any
other questions thank you very much
good morning Madam chair and esteemed
Representatives I just wanted to be
available for any questions so I don't
know if there's any questions at oplc
can answer for this board I
representative broa you is this a tech a
procedural
well no this this compact
is is new but we are in a number of
other compacts correct that is correct
represent of scitech well you're the guy
to answer uh what's going on with uh
dieticians from the military are they
going to be coded in or sure where's the
status of that yeah so we have a number
of um we're in rule making process so
the legislature passed as you as you
guys well know you passed a statute um
that requires uh the rul is to be done I
think by 2 it's either 26 or 27 so we're
in the process of having we have two
part-time rules coordinators as well as
a full-time one and they're in the
process of going to each of the 57
boards and working with them on putting
together rules so I don't know
specifically where dieticians is but I
can tell you that they are one of those
57 boards and they will be
addressed okay sometime yes okay thank
you that's if we have any specific
questions we'll call you back all right
Costello good morning my name is
Courtney Costello I am a licensed
dietitian and owner of a private
practice here in New Hampshire I'm here
to express my support for House Bill 145
which proposes background checks for
licensed dietitians and adopting the die
dietician lure compact um requiring
background checks uh for dietitians is
vital to protect Public Safety and
representative Lane you asked a question
about why that would be necessary given
that dietitians practice in group
settings um I just wanted to clarify a
lot of times dietitians work in K
through 12s um they also work on
one-on-one with with patients in um
either a private practice setting that
could be virtually that could also be in
person um so it's not just in group
settings it's it can also be one-on-one
so I think it's important that we
protect the public safety and have safe
practitioners practicing
um The dietitian L lure compact is a
Forward Thinking initiative with
numerous benefits for our state um the
compact firstly the compact improves
access to care in my practice we have
dietitians licensed in at least seven
states yet we frequently encounter
situations where a patient relocates to
a state where their dietitian is not
licensed this disruption of care can be
significant in outpatient nutrition
counseling building rapport with
patients is essential for creating
personalized strategies that Inspire
meaningful Behavior change
addressing the complex challenges of
food and nutrition often requ requires a
deep understanding of the social and
emotional factors influencing a patients
choices continuity of care is especially
important for patients struggling with
eating disorders there's a shortage of
dietitians who work with this population
Nationwide but especially here in New
Hampshire often these patients are
students who go to college in another
state this disruption of care may not
only be inconvenient but it can be
dangerous establishing trust with a
provider takes time and cannot be easily
transferred to a new practitioner if
you've ever tried to find a new primary
care provider you know how disruptive
and timeconsuming and frankly
frustrating it can be tell health is
well suited for nutrition counseling our
practi is almost exclusively tella
Health the compact expands teleah Health
opportunities especially benefiting
Rural and unders communities that
struggle to Access Nutrition Counseling
Services secondly Workforce Mobility as
previously mentioned with the military I
think that's pretty straightforward um
certain um the military does employ
dietitians um to do nutrition counseling
and various other other things uh lastly
economic growth by removing barriers to
practice the compact attracts talented
professionals to our exceptional State
and broadens access to care for granite
Staters in my practice we have patients
who live outside of New Hampshire for
part of the year for example we have
patients who live over theboard in
Massachusetts but summer in New
Hampshire um or patients who live in New
Hampshire and then spend the winters
somewhere down south um um it's not
realistic to obtain licenses in other
states depending on where the patient
spends their Summers or Winters
currently that revenue is simply lost
for that portion of the year and the
care is
disrupted so in conclusion um House Bill
145 is a vital piece of legislation that
enhances Public Safety improves access
to care contributes to economic growth
and strengthens the dietetics profession
by imple implementing background checks
and adopting the dietician lure compact
our state can lead the way in ensuring
high quality accessible nut rtion
services for all so I urge you I urge
the committee to pass House Bill 145
thank you for considering my testimony
questions thank you representative
scitech are there are there states where
dieticians are not licensed
yes uh have I follow follow up yes
um you have a p you have a client
patient who lives you mentioned tella
Health yes and I'm want to follow up on
that because that's a bumpy road for me
I don't really have a good feel for it
your patient moves to Colorado can you
continue to uh or to can you continue to
uh work with that
patient in another state this is tell I
don't know whether your license here
permits you to practice in Colorado so
we have to be licensed where the patient
resides
yes the the with tell Health the
location in in question is the one where
the patient is not where the doctor is
so you'd have to get credentials in
Colorado which is not likely to be a
compact state well in any case you need
credentials of some sort in Colorado
correct okay thank
you representative Pierce to jump jump
on representative scitec question though
in a state that does not have licensing
at all no problem there shouldn't be a
problem right you would have no
prohibition of because if there's no
license there's no violation correct
right and they would not be eligible to
enter the compact because they don't
have a license sure
okay representative
schmidth thank you madam chair well I
alluded in my earlier questioning of Mr
Mr Grady to my previous service in the
military so I'm very concerned about ma
situations where where a diean is
working or Food Services provided to a
large number of people such as in a
hospital we don't we used to have lots
of very large corporations frequently
they would provide food service at the
job on the job okay that's less the case
now than it was previously but hospitals
for example or other large uh entities
that provide food service uh it it's a
real problem if you have people who are
working with food providing food who are
not properly trained because you can do
a lot of damage when you're feeding a
lot of people obviously so um do you
know you know whether uh your
organization uh you know is checking on
whether hospitals for example have
licensed di
ties so in other words the question is
are are these entities ensuring that
dietitians are licensed that's the
underlying issue of course whether the
the whether you have somebody working in
a in a food service that provides uh
that has access to a large C clientele
where a a bad egg shall we say uh you
know can cause a lot of damage because
they're feeding a lot of people I I I
frequently eat at the Wentworth Douglas
Hospital cafet IA my assumption is that
their dietitians are licensed so I'm
going to get a better quality of food a
better quality of diet and food
selection excuse me representative
Schmidt the question of whether someone
is licensed when they're working in a
hospital is a matter of current statute
it has nothing to do with this bill okay
well I I I that I appreciate that
clarification that solves my problem
thank you okay thank you very much much
are there any other
questions all right yes thank you for
your testimony thank you so much I have
three people from the New Hampshire
Academy of nutrition and dietetics are
you together or uh separate separate all
pyer good morning thank you madam chair
committee members my name is Kate fifel
I am a registered dietician and a
licensed dietician I live and work in
New Hampshire just for the record I'm
here in support of the compact lure you
know the dietician compact bill at House
Bill 145 I ask for your
support some of the points I was going
to make have already been spoken I just
wanted to emphasize it is a privilege
compact liken to similar to a driver's
license um just to clarify if anyone was
wondering and we've already touched on
the tella health I just wanted to
emphasize that preco we were fast
approaching the transformation of the
delivery of health care which was tella
health I was receiving my ma working on
my Master's Degree and that was all that
was the topic during Co we had to rely
heavily on it thankfully we had started
that Journey postco
not only is it convenient I believe
consumers have grown to expect it and we
need it as previously testim testimony
was given about that continuity of care
we have to provide that continuity we
have a lot of rural communities in New
Hampshire and it's interesting to note
that about 45 to 50 million Americans
live in rural rural communities and they
actually represent the highest incidence
of some of the top five chronic diseases
um and so having access to be able to
give the mobility to dietitians
especially living on a border state if
we can get our neighbors to also be part
of the compact allows for that Mobility
for the dietician to work with the
patients um in the different states and
also as already mentioned our military
and their spouses they are constantly as
we've already heard
relocated um and it just streamlines
that process for them they have the
highest unemployment rate the spouses of
military I believe it's
21% um so this would help um with their
concerns as well um one point to make
and I think this was already said um was
that the member state or you know New
Hampshire would have they would retain
sole
jurisdiction
um over the provision of all the
requirements not the commission of the
not the compact commission has some
rules but New Hampshire would maintain
that sovereignty and to become I think
you were asking earlier Madam chair
about the requirements to become a
registered dietician you have to meet a
dactic program it is uh a 4-year
bachelor's degree about a thousand
practical hours if you are accepted into
the it used to be a match program now
you're accepted into a program once
you've completed that and met the the
the requirements you are eligible to sit
for a national registration exam The
Lure further helps when you apply for
that license it also helps with the
language of a lot of uh reimbursements
through Insurance require you to be
licensed um and I'm not sure if that was
mentioned earlier so I just wanted to
again emphasize that we want to protect
that public health the safety the
welfare of our residents and to do so we
need a little bit more than that
reciprocity we want to be able to keep
that sole jurisdiction over all the
jurist Prudence that is met through our
licensing requirements while we work
with the other states you have to
maintain your home requirements and so
to be part of a compact and also be in
the New Hampshire compact you have to
meet the Juris Prudence of New Hampshire
and so I just wanted to make sure that
that was clear as well um I'm happy to
take any questions that someone might
have representative scitech I have two
questions first uh is you started by
saying you're a registered and a
licensed what is the distinction why did
you say that yes so to me become a
registered dietitian you have to meet
all of the requirements to take the
national exam and pass it and then you
can then to further protect that and
protect the public you have to apply for
a license in order to practice in the
state the second question is there is a
national Examination for die
that's what the registration exam is
just like a nursing exam it's a national
um accredited you have to meet certain
requirements it's or that's part of our
credential it's our national
credential thank you yes represent pear
so they're tied together in essence you
have to be registered to be licensed
correct and the okay and there's no oh
gotcha yeah perfect yes and in order to
work in a lot of facilities it's a
requirement to answer um representative
schmidth you to work in a hospital you
have to be a registered and licensed
dietitian whether you work in food
service or in clinical care um the other
point was that if you're working in a
grant funded program you might work in
community health and some of these
grants are short term and so a lot of
dietitians do contract work in addition
to private practice and they're moving
around from entity to entity um and so
those aren't clinical settings but
they're shortterm and so they need that
mob ability to move around to have the
flexibility to work in various locations
especially being on a border state it
just would make it it it would improve
the mobility improve the workforce and
also allow for that continuity of the
care so thank you representative Leon uh
thank you madam chair um is
Massachusetts already signed to this
compact no they have not they just
signed their very first compact which is
the nursing compact which is not the
same as this compact structure um
Massachusetts New York and California I
believe the only states that really
aren't that compact heavy yet um New
Hampshire is a little bit more than
middle we're actually on the higher end
um there are 15 other occupational uh
compacts and
um they are working in Massachusetts and
um working on the language some of the
States you mentioned someone mentioned
that that don't have lure uh that's a
very limited group and that had to do
with their own State Legislature and
passing that that legislation and I know
they're all working on that in
Massachusetts right now uh our Academy
is we're working with the language of
how their Pathways could be to get to
compact that's where they're at right
now follow follow up um and I probably
should have asked a previous speaker but
do you know about Florida um are they
already signed because it's been
mentioned both about people going from M
from New Hampshire to Massachusetts and
New Hampshire to Florida so I'm looking
to see how relevant this particular
compact is for those hire it's the the
no the other states are Alabama Nebraska
Ohio and Tennessee right and Florida is
extremely resistant to not only compacts
but other forms of reciprocity okay they
don't want people coming in and
working uh we do have other dietitians
who also um leave the state themselves
and I know of one in particular who
lives in New Hampshire and she goes to
Arizona for three months of the year
with her husband's job and she's thought
about maybe applying for a license but
it's very tedious to follow the you know
the education requirements in that um
cycle and the New Hampshire license so
she has not and she's really hopeful
that maybe Arizona will adopt that
compact where she can easily work in
both thank you welcome any other
questions thank you for your testimony
thank you madam chair members of the
committee my name is Victor Muzzy I am a
captain with the state police that
oversees the criminal uh Records unit
and with that obviously the
dissemination of both state criminal
conviction and FBI related criminal
history um histories so we don't take a
position on the bill um per se except to
make everybody aware that where it
includes an FBI um record in this case
um this bill should it pass is going to
be required to be submitted to the FBI
legal unit for review and
approval that process unfortunately can
take many months in order to to um
receive that approval review and
approval and it's unfortunately the law
unit does not review draft language
anymore so we don't even have the
ability to kind of proactively submit
this to see if it's going to meet their
standard relative to the to the
dissemination of their record so um I
offer you that I see that the the
effective date would be 60 days after
the passage um should that happen um
that's fine except that the state police
will not be authorized to disseminate
any FBI record until it's been reviewed
and approved by that that outfit so that
certainly would be prohibitive obviously
to to the intended result here which is
um to provide requisite information for
folks making the determination about
one's suitability so I offer that
information as a as a potential delay to
be able to execute upon uh the Bill
thank you that's valuable information uh
as a side note in previous years we've
had reports of backlogs for criminal
record checks is that still the case
absolutely not n you've cleared it up
cleared it up completely cleared been
cleared at least a year now excellent
thank you very much represent citech
this went a little fast would you mind
walking me through what it what what
happens when you get a request for a
happens well I guess that I have to ask
you for which part of the process a
state record check is typically name and
date of birth driven so if we have your
name and date of birth we can provide
you a record that we may have based upon
that name and date of birth if we're
talking about an FBI record check uh
that comes with a submission of
fingerprints and so to say it quite
simply the FBI doesn't necessarily care
what your name and date of birth is they
care what your fingertips look like and
that's how they um identify folks within
their records and in their system and so
really the benefit to that is um you
know who you're dealing with it's it's
difficult to change your fingerprints as
everyone's likely aware go ahead uh of
the chair follow
up what this says criminal background
check what's that
mean well according to the language that
presented here that means a state
criminal conviction check and an FBI and
it's a two-part two-part okay correct
the FBI part can take months state is
fast absolutely not the approval for us
to disseminate the FBI record check is
going to take months once the approval
of this language for us to disseminate
their record pursuant to this language
has been approved it's going to be as
quick as any check is today for an
approved authorized statute the the FBI
doesn't have any backlog in fact they're
required to get back to us within 48
Hours of our submission of fingerprints
with a result so what takes the months
the approval of the language so in other
words I have to submit this RSA to the
FBI legal unit who is going to review
within the confines of the RSA whether
it
meets the standard for dissemination
under Public Law
92544 for us to be able to disseminate
their
record Captain but Captain that's a
one-time thing correct okay then after
that correct all right correct one time
thing that's what I'm saying is this is
brand new legislation and even if it's
even if it weren't it was simply being
modified the approval process in order
for us to disseminate the record can
take months that's the only thing that
takes months my
apologies and you you also said that
they will not look at draft language
they'll only look at it after it's been
signed by the governor Essen they used
to they've discontinued that practice as
of about a year ago because they were
likely getting too many requests so to
remedy that situation and we've we've
seen a return on a submission in as
little as eight months I think and as
long as we're still waiting for some and
it's been over a year for whatever
reason and it might be contingent upon
the depth of review that is required
based upon the submitted the submitted
RSA and so what I would suggest to
somewhat alleviate this um in the future
future where it's involving it's fine if
it's just a state record check right a
state record check is our record we can
do what we choose with it within State
no big deal um the effective date for
those types of things that only involve
a state check and come much more
expeditiously when we're talking about
an FBI record uh fingerprint supported
record check that's where we're at the
mercy of the FBI legal unit basically um
and so my my suggestion or
recommendation would be a um as as we've
testified for a two or three years now
the sooner the state police criminal
records unit can get involved in in New
Or revised um language that's being put
forward in any session the better so
that we can help craft that language
with the sponsoring folks in order to
make sure it'll meet what we believe to
be the standard of the law unit
additional to that um certainly making
the effective date of um those changes a
year two years out from when it passes
would be helpful now I know that's
inhibitive in this case because we're
talking about a compact and doing other
things um relative you know that that
involve a criminal records check however
that that's about the only two
suggestions that I can make to help
alleviate a conundrum that we're going
to find ourselves in where this has
passed the state is expecting us to be
able to do it yet we're at the mercy of
the FBI who has yet to you review and
approve it so thank you uh this bill
would if passed besides the compact it
requires it for a criminal record check
for every new
license not for existing licenses
interestingly but for any new licy and
we had how many was
it uh like 20 or
so new applicants every
year uh and there's almost 1200 licensed
dietitians so this would put all
all of the criminal record checks would
be on hold until the FBI finished their
um under the authority of the statute
yes yep okay thank you and
um this will be going to subcommittee so
if you have any suggestions about the
language we would very much appreciate
them because we'll be we'll be glad to
work with you to make sure it um doesn't
trip up the FBI any more than necessary
certainly and I I think we will probably
continue to track this so we will likely
appear at that that subcommittee meeting
if we don't what I can offer um right
right in the first instance here is um I
don't know I think it's repeated several
times um in in the first section here um
where it refers to the office now
generally speaking I understand that is
likely the office of oplc however that
language in in in our recent experience
with the uh FBI legal unit might be a
little broad they like to see things
like will be released to the executive
director Human Resources administrator
um a little bit more specific title
because the office can imply well is
that the janitor in the office is that
the administrative assistant and things
so while I'm not saying that it'll fail
for that expressly but U myself and and
Christine think about it longer right
myself and Christine Shay here um as the
CSO on the compact officer for the State
of New Hampshire are are basically
charged with trying to vet these things
ahead of sending them to the FBI and our
experience has been that many of the uh
prior submissions we've had have failed
due to being too broad quite frankly
sometimes we get a slight amount of
feedback as to how to make it less broad
or why it's too broad but not very often
do we get some sort of narrowing or
focused language so in reading this
having the word office there might be a
little bit problematic a little bit
Broad and if if that can be revised in
some way shape or form to include a
specific title of person or persons that
would actually be receiving and
reviewing the record that that may
help it's certainly appropriate because
we heard last year that whether it says
executive director or office it means
the same thing so if the FBI wants to
see executive director in this language
that seems like a straightforward fix
sure you know something more specific
than than than office so I apologize
representative scitec for my Broad
definition and I I will reiterate that
what I'm speaking about relative to any
delay is simply the approval of this
once it's been approved it's business as
usual in record checks will'll be flying
out the door and off the shelves just as
quickly as we can with zero backlog so
the only backlog is initially upon
approval of it so sorry about that thank
you and and I I I would be concerned
that would also stop the licensing of
any state
specific dietitians because of that
and I'm not aware now if this exists or
if this is brand new I I so I don't know
that it would affect any other
pre-existing statute that isn't this one
so um for what probably not thank you
correct all right thank you for the
information any questions representative
Schmidt thank you madam chair so uh you
referenced the fact that there was a
tremendous
bottleneck this committee is is familiar
with the fact that the criminal
background check was uh was the one of
the major F
factors excuse me one of the major
factors in that bottleneck and
fingerprints were one of the key aspects
that was causing problem because um you
have to get the the the fingerprinting
is a is a highly skilled
uh function involved in all of this and
if the fingerprint is improperly created
by the an
inexpert
uh yes official usually a forign officer
I think uh but there are machines that
can immediately recognize whether the
fingerprint works or not and also it can
be immediately submitted submitted
electronically and you can get a very
fast so are the but there weren't very
many of these machines in New Hampshire
at the time only about 40 I think are
there more of them out there now because
that it it's like lightning you put your
hand on the glass the machine lights up
green that the fingerprints are going to
be good and bang it gets forward
electronically so we we have one in
Dover in the police department so I can
answer that yeah we are I think north of
90 machines now 90 90 0 yep and we will
I think right now we our maintenance
budget will support we think about a
hundred without you know increasing that
that maintenance budget and so um for
the last several years we've we have
been successful in being able to Ploy
about 10 machines a year we're at the
point now where we're going to start
replacing some of the older end of life
machines so we may only purchase five or
so new ones um we've been fortunate
enough to be able to purchase these
machines through through grant funding
to buy them the machine it's the
maintenance that we have to incur the
the the additional cost thereof um and
just for the record relative to an aphis
machine it's called you you are correct
um you do have to be trained to take
fingerprints on an aphis machine that
training is is fairly simple I suppose
um and and and how to do it it's the
machine that's smart not that the people
aren't but it's the machine that's smart
and knows um um when a a good print has
been established or when there's an
issue and things like that so just to
just to clear up any misconception I
suppose given this opportunity um while
the fingerprints are captured on the
machine they're not submitted as soon as
you hit submit or as soon as you hit
save um those fingerprints actually have
to be processed by a group of eight
people that we have in the office so
every fingerprint that's taken in the
state whether it's for an applicant um
or a criminal which could be an
applicant one day is it has to be
actually processed by uh the folks on on
the criminal records unit before it's
submitted to the FBI that that
processing time is minutes I'll say for
each of those files if you will or
fingerprint submissions but does require
human human intervention so I don't want
to quote television here or anything
like that but it's it's not quite as
simple as you put your fingers on the
box and a criminal record spits out the
back of the machine not that that's what
you said sir but just to clarify that
there there is a little bit in that
process what the aphis machine does
though um outside of what we call ink
prints which is everyone's probably
familiar with a fingerprint card with
you dip your fingers in ink and you roll
them on a fingerprint
card the machine obviously does save a
few steps um not only in the quality
control um aspect of it but obviously
the submission of it being electronic
because for every ink card that we get
in the office and we still do get some
we actually have to scan those in to the
system whereby obviously the ones we get
from the machine are already in in in
the system for us to process so it it is
a Time save uh saver um we have trained
other entities to be able to use these
Beyond law enforcement some of the
statutes now include language like a
qualified law enforcement officer or a
qualified uh employee of oplc for
example or Department of Education or
something like that we've we have
trained and sat in on trainings for
Department of Ed and other entities to
sort of help um enlarge I guess the
folks that we have available for us uh
to take fingerprints and and capture
those things and stuff so we are pretty
proud of the infrastru structure that we
have at the moment and proud of the
progress that we've made in the past
couple of years in clearing up the
backlog um and quite delighted to
illustrate in every again in every
opportunity because we know things are
always delayed right so you folks were
under the impression a few minutes ago
that a backlog may still exist um but
yet it's been a year or better actually
really where we have not had any backlog
at all um but that message takes some
time to get out there and so um we're in
a pretty good position right now
relative to the submission of of
fingerprints for required background
checks and the turnaround time on those
and um that that has come at the the
diligent hands of the work that's been
done by the unit over the past two years
so I have a quick follow very much I
have a quick quick followup so one of
the one of the bottlenecks was SW it had
to be a sworn officer are these
technicians you were talking about are
they considered sworn officers in terms
of being able to process no no no the
bill in fact mentions that the
fingerprints are taken by a qualified
law enforcement agency or an authorized
employee of safety cor is does the oplc
have any qualified employees at the
moment not to my knowledge but they
certainly can if they call us okay well
that that might make things easier for
other cases thank you very much for
Testimony other
questions okay
good morning Madam chair and members of
the committee um I'd like to say I
appreciate the time today given to me to
speak in support of House Bill 145 I am
a licensed registered dietitian and a
certified Diabetes Care and education
specialist it used to be just diabetes
educator but they changed our credential
um I currently hold 18 state licenses
throughout the country
um and I live in Deerfield New Hampshire
and I worked at Dartmouth and conquered
hospital for many years for about 20
years I now work for a large company
that makes remote patient monitoring
devices so we have a blood sugar meter a
blood Su a blood pressure cuff and a
weight scale for heart failure so I
provide um education to my patients
across the country um by phone and
I cannot talk to them until I'm licensed
in that state um or if the state doesn't
require a
lure um one of my main focus focus is
providing maternal health education to
um all three Medicaid programs in
Georgia so um there are three Medicaid
major Medicaid programs in Georgia the
state passed a bill to cover maternal
Health in these R rural areas so these
women can talk to me or one of my
colleagues every one to two weeks about
nutrition we also have nurses but um
again I have to have a state license in
Georgia in order to help these
women and they have gestational diabetes
and high blood pressure and um even
pre-existing diabetes during
pregnancy uh the majority of my patients
do have Medicaid so we work with
um I think eight Medicaid programs
throughout this the country in different
states
and I've had patients so one example I
want to share with you is a patient
story um a we work with the National
Association of letter carriers and so my
patient lived in Port Li in New
York which is about an hour above UDA
New York so there's nothing up there so
I was not able to help this person with
um cardiovascular and and diabetes
education until I was licensed and it
took 6 months to license me in New
York um I've had four background checks
in one year for the state of Ohio Nevada
Indiana and the state of
Washington and I asked if I could share
those results and they said no um I'm
providing written testimony what I gave
you today shows all my licenses and the
fees that are associated with those and
the due dates to
renew all of the the renewal dates are
very different some go by your birthday
some are one year some are two years but
basically almost every month of the year
I'm renewing a
license um so I really hope that you can
hopefully support this bill um the Rd
the registered dietician and the
cdce certified Diabetes Care and
education specialist CR itial are
nationally recognized but we just need a
license in each state to in the states
that require lure to help our patients
um I won't repeat what other people have
said but I am open to questions if you
have any questions I can take that now
and I thank you for your time thank you
are there
questions representative
sers thank you madam
chair so I again this has to deal with
licensing and I'm just trying
to I'm I'm on a part that says let's
reduce licensing but this is increasing
it so do you really see that this is
really necessary and as far as if I have
tella Health someone's helped me over
the phone from another state do they
need to get a license here in New
Hampshire if we pass this they do they
do
now
yes
yeah yes we we
a couple of years ago we explicitly
defined that the case of tella Health if
the patients in New Hampshire they
require New Hampshire license except in
very narrow circumstances follow up I
did used to work at the wick program for
the State of New Hampshire and we did
not require a license so a wick diet a
wick can be a nutritionist not a
dietician so they can have their
four-year bachelor's degree um but as
far as I know they may not still still
need one but when I worked for Wick I
did not need a license but when you go
into the healthcare field and deal with
insurance reimbursements do you need a
license so follow up yeah thank you
madam chair so again I guess I'm looking
at the background check on this is is
why is that necessary now were wasn't
necessary before I think um in order to
draw ATT in order to be attracted by
other states other states require the
background check and we we never did so
I think when they when they created the
compact uh language they wanted to
include some basic things that other
states wanted and quite a few of them do
want background checks and I know it's a
for me it's it's a lot of work and
annoying because I had four in one year
but um I think they made the rules a
little bit more um
tight than less in hopes that other
states that already included the
background check would would come aboard
so Ohio was one of them and they they
they would not accept my background
check from another state um and so I
don't know I think that's why I think
they're just trying to check all the
boxes and make sure they get all the
main points um CDR the commission on
dietetic registration is the governing
body that oversees our dietitian
credential and so um
you cannot get to that point unless you
have your bachelor's degree your a
thousand hours of internship you're
passing the exam you you maintain 75
hours of continuing education every five
years so when all these other states ask
for your undergraduate transcripts your
you know Social Security I had one ask
for a social security card a photo um
and they ask for my exam scores I I just
think it's frustrating because if you
get to the level of CDR they make sure
you have all of those things already
there and and they do ask you know have
you have you had any felonies you have
to check off all these boxes that say
have you um had anybody sue you and
things like that so um but yes so I'm
very passionate about this issue so if
you have any questions I can you know
hopefully
answer yeah would it be fair to say that
the compact is just to solve the
problems people have with other states
ridiculous requirements I think so um
one ridiculous example if I have time um
my education was too old for New York
State I graduated in 1998 I've been a
clinical dietitian diabetes educator for
20 years and they had to send my
application to a separate Council in
order to see if I needed to take any
more undergraduate coursework and I was
at at UNH for seven years and um
so it kept getting delayed because my
application had to get approved by a
second board so six months for New York
that's what I that was the longest one
and the fees are all different Indiana
is $20 New York was 294 so I just I feel
like this would bring it all together
and just make it a lot easier for us to
give the patient care that we we need so
also working with I work with a lot of
dietitians and nurses from Louisiana
Texas all over and we gain diversity
from learning from our fellow dietitians
that work in these other states and also
from patients so the patients that what
they eat in Texas is different than what
we might eat up in New England so we're
very much um surrounded by diverse um
food issues cultural issues too if you
could say so okay thank you very much
other
questions okay thank you
chadburn good morning Madam chair and
members of the committee my name is
Jennifer chadborn I live in Auburn New
Hampshire I'm a registered dietitian I'm
also a certified Diabetes Care and
education specialist similar to Tina I
work as a clinical assistant professor
at the University of New Hampshire in
Durham and I serve as the Director of
the teleah health curriculum for the UNH
Center for digital Health
Innovation I'm here today to speak in
strong support of HB 145 the registered
dietitian lure compact I have been a
tella Health provider since
2015 my journey with tella health
started when I joined a startup that was
aimed at delivering nutrition services
remotely and our goal was to reach
underserved populations where long
travel times and Associated costs often
prevented access to registered
dietitians and teleah health allowed us
to bring Services directly to those who
needed it the most however managing
cross state lure was a significant
challenge as you've already started to
hear about today lure as you know now is
dictated by the state in which the
client is located in that means if I
support someone who's traveling I must
be licensed in every state they pass
through during our interactions and I
have had that scenario happen before
where someone was traveling across the
country and it was very challenging to
maintain um care for that
person cross state lure can also disrupt
care for people like college students um
those at UNH who work with our oncampus
registered dietician but live across the
border in Maine or go home to other
States during academic breaks at times I
held lure in over 10 states each with
different require requirements fees and
renewal processes for example some
states do require fingerprinting which
has been referenced already um While
others require child abuse training I
believe that was Texas um if I'm
recalling correctly this was complicated
to navigate timec consuming and costly
it also involved complex tracking of
continuing education requirements and
the fees associated in order to
unintentionally let a license lapse in
another role that I held we actually
couldn't work to our full scope of
practice as registered dietitians
because the burden of obtaining lure
across multiple States was too great for
the company who I worked for to pursue
and maintain as a result our capacity to
serve clients was highly limited
countless times I found myself in
conversations with clients equipped with
the Knowledge and Skills to help them um
but I was actually unable to do so
simply because of lure restrictions
these were critical missed opportunities
and if I'm being frank quite um
frustrating moments for myself as a
provider HB 145 the registered dietician
lure compact addresses these issues by
allowing dietitians to practice across
state lines with a single license this
will enhance access to essential
nutrition services especially in our
underserved in rural areas it will also
promote continuity of care allowing
patients to maintain relationships
relationships with their dietician
regardless of of State
boundaries moreover this compact will
reduce administrative burdens and costs
enabling dietitians to focus more on
client care which is what we want to
spend our time doing this efficiency
benefits both dietitians and the Health
Care System leading to better resource
allocation and improved outcomes which
is crucial right now in light of the
workforce shortages that we are
facing many of my students are rising
nutrition professionals expressed
excitement at my presence here today and
not simply because I had to cancel class
to be here U but because of the
potential this bill has in shaping their
future careers and expanding their reach
in serving our communities I urge you to
support HB 145 the registered dietician
lure Compact and appreciate your time in
listening today and I'm happy to answer
any questions that you might have thank
you are there any
questions no I think the other people
caught most of them just wish that you
had brought your class with you I they
would have loved to be here um but they
had other classes today besides just my
own oh well that's shows how they they
feel about it uh no other questions
thank you for your
testimony is there any I just for your
benefit this is all being recorded so uh
your class can can at least view the
tape yes if you can figure out how to
get ad I will have to do that I think
they would enjoy it on
YouTube they'll probably show they'll
probably critique your performance I'm
sure they will they'll have lots to say
all right is there anyone else who
wishes to testify on House Bill
yes thank you madam chair and committee
I think I'm the cleanup batter and I'll
be brief um for the record I'm state
representative hope Damon Sullivan
County District 8 there are nine towns I
will save the time of listing and I
serve on the education funding policy
committee however I had a very rewarding
45y year career as a dietitian and
diabetes educator hence my personal
interest in vigorously supporting this
bill um I was Hospital based for the
first several years of my career and
then was in private practice in New
London for 35 years um as has been noted
there
are um situations where people are
mobile we're an increasingly mobile
Society many of my patients were people
with complicated diagnosis such as
diabetes and eating disorders these are
not conditions that go away we don't
have cures for them they need treatment
for a lifetime and the treatment needs
to be kept up Tod date to fit the
patients needs and increasing
knowledge dietitians develop a
relationship with their patients as do
many healthcare providers providers and
it is hard for people to transition to
other folks so both for Mobility reasons
whether it's a snowbird who Winters in
the South or a college student or people
who work remotely from different parts
of the country this would really
facilitate continuity of care I would
further note in this has not been said
when I retired in December of 22 and I
had decided to retire and close my
practice the winter before and that I
would spend that year winding down if
you will
the hardest part of doing that was that
there were not enough people available
to refer my patients to and I had
already gone from a very busy full-time
practice to three days a week and I had
stopped taking new patients 18 months
before I closed my practice and yet for
the significant number of remaining
patients finding people who were taking
new P patients
who
had serious eating disorder or
complicated diabetes situations the
weight lists were so
long it was very distressful to both me
and my patients if we had this compact
in place at that time in December 22 it
would have been a whole lot easier to
line Folks up with providers to give
them the continuity of care that they
need and
I think the other points that I would
make have been said um I would just
throw in one other piece when people are
newly diagnosed with a
condition that is often the time when
they are most
receptive to acquiring knowledge and
changing behaviors to take good care of
themselves so if we are telling a person
say with newly diagnosed diabetes that
they can't be seen by a dietitian
diabetes educator for 3 months
we're kind of saying but you'll be okay
your condition's not that significant
which is not true so again timeliness of
care and continuity is very important um
thank you for the time and effort you
all put in happy to answer questions now
or
subsequently any questions
representative sers thank you madam
chair so your belief in this cont
compact will actually ease that case
because I've seen it in other practices
as well uh I have a grandson that's
waiting six months to see a uh what is
it a dentist that will actually pull a
tooth for example so so you think this
compact will actually ease that because
you'd be able to get people from other
states correct um whether via T Health
or by the reality that if you're a
bordering state and you don't need
multiple licenses I didn't reiterate in
my testimony but I had a Vermont license
as well as a New Hampshire license
because living in New London or working
in New London I was close enough that I
had
cross the border um but yes and and I
empathize with the dental situation
which is an acute problem as
well other
questions right seeing none thank you
very much thank you is there anyone else
who wishes to testify on House Bill
145 all right they don't see any that
case I'm closing the public
hearing the this will go to subcommittee
and the house bill
2114 will the PO the hearing will be
yes
back
e
hello and welcome back to Edna I will
open the hearing for House Bill 214 and
up good afternoon Madame chair members
of the committee I'm Carol Maguire marac
District
27 and House Bill 214 is a request of
the
oplc to clarify
the ru making Authority and other
statutory sections with regard to
recreational therapists and Respiratory
Care
practitioners
um it's as requested so if you have any
questions I'll try to answer them
um I will mention that the first section
is a very nice and uh breakdown of the
rulemaking authority so I can can
recommend that to other people if you're
looking for a good
one anything else any questions from the
committee representative
gr thank you representative Maguire does
this bill um result from the transition
of the recreational therapist to an
Advisory
Board um I don't know for sure if that
was the O the main or the only reason
thank you I have a question after the
testimony in the previous Bill about the
background checks did you have a chance
to see if this language uh meets what
what was suggested on the other bill or
if we should out to them it looks to me
as though that if it's going to go
forward it should have the executive
director language inserted in a couple
of different places so it it would need
to be uh examined if there are other
issues I'll uh if there are no other
issues I'll work on an amendment
otherwise it'll have to go to sub
commmittee
other questions from the committee
representative sers thank you madam
chair so again I'm looking at this of
course I'm new to Edna so forgive me but
I mean background checks I mean why is I
I get in some cases are necessary but I
I don't understand why we're you you
know forcing
these that's a very good question it's
as I said this was a request and I
didn't question whether they need they
already had or really needed background
checks I kind of think
unnecessary representative
Bailey oh could you turn your microphone
on
please I I've noticed in the past that
there was sometimes a definitional thing
up front that's saying OPC is equal to
the office and then you can say office
is that the solution to the prior one
and this one it's
um it does say this at some places not
in the bill directly but
um from the lieutenant I got the
impression that the FBI was only looking
at that specific section
so if we wanted to include a specific
section talking about FBI background
checks we ought to make sure the
language is the way they like it thank
you other questions from the committee
you Mr Fry would you like to come thank
good afternoon so appreciate you guys
having me and um I want to start with
his question about background checks so
part of the process is trying to um have
a universal standard for folks that are
in
healthcare everyone nurses doctors or
Physicians um are subject to that
criminal background check um recre uh
recreational
therapists um which were previously
under Allied Health if you go to the
Allied Health statute there's actually a
criminal records statute that reflects
in that so what we're trying to do with
Respiratory Care is to bring them into
the same umbrella that the rest of the
in thank you that's helpful
representative Pearson thank
you in reference to the discussion we
had on the prior Bill and apparently on
this bill as well as far as the language
of the FBI seems to like for that do we
already have one that's been vetted in
one of the 57 variety boards that we
have do we already have one that the
FBI's come back and been okay with that
we can just use as a model for the rest
of them that is a great question um
that's actually the question I was
asking the officer or the captain when
um after he finished testifying he did
give me a statute uh for Department of
Education to take a look at so we may be
able to borrow some language from that
and hopefully just make sure that it's
universalized follow up Department of
Education is not under oplc yep so
that's not going to work I I need
something that has has come through the
oplc and that way as an agency right
because the point of the oplc was to
consolidate and make things streamlined
and similar and all that right so if we
have a standard background check
paragraph that we use in these statutes
that that have the require IR M of a
background check then I think that might
make life a lot easier right for the
office I I agree and I understand what
you're saying but so the point that he
was getting at is
using instead of using like broad
language of office getting into the
specific so I'm not saying this is going
to be a perfect statute to look at but I
think what he was getting at in
recommending us to look at that is that
that statute uses um executive director
for example or I mean or language that
would be similar to that right so we
want to use moving forward I think what
he's saying is we need to use language
that's more specific to folks that are
actually or um positions that are in the
office so if we can take a look at that
statute and see how they've done it
right so if they have their their head
and their general counsel I don't know
because I haven't looked at this statute
yet and then try to model hours after
that so that we're using similar
language that the FBI would have looked
at in their
statute prob look at the Physicians or
nurses or any of the other
stat we correct because one of these
boards has must have already been
approved I I don't disagree with that I
think what he's saying is is the the
problem is the expediency of it right so
if we're using this broad language even
if those have been previously approved
that may be what the hiccup is so his
recommendation was if we start using
titles and to me it would um and if I
can ask a question is your understanding
that we may have some that previously
were approved by the FBI that may not be
quite as tied up as they would like
today and if we don't have that language
in the oplc you want to look to another
more recently enacted background check
language from any other part of state
government that we know was approved by
the FDA and this FBI in this program so
that we can get as close as we can
without perhaps opening up another one
and asking them for a review on
something that's already functioning
correct I think what he's saying or at
least as I understood it in speaking
with him is that it's not that our
statutes aren't getting approved but
they're being held up and it seems like
this sort of more specific language of
what are the positions in the agency
that are reviewing these criminal
background checks is helping those move
forward quicker thank you there
representative Bailey but in the past
they I think they've told us that saying
executive director was the same as
saying office and but just you put a
specific person's name or title in there
she's she or he is not looking at every
single one somebody in the office is
doing that so it's kind isn't this all a
distinction without a difference uh so I
I believe you've dealt with some of the
rules with Department of Health and
Human Services and I remember on some of
those we have said the commissioner
design um and the some of the what we
probably would ask you if it's a
reasonable ask is to see if or design is
something that's been accepted elsewhere
y thank
you representative sers thank you madam
chair I'll be honest what I'm getting
hung up with is the criminal background
check okay and to me if you need to get
relicensed or you know or new you have
to have one of these submitted and not
and not only that I mean it's one thing
having a records check it's a certain
another thing having your fingernail uh
fingerprints I mean I just think it's
over intrusive on government to be
forcing this on just because a person
needs a license in this
case um recreational therapist and so on
right so I mean do you really think that
these people really need a criminal
background check I mean will it will it
ever stopped there will be plumbers and
Carpenters or electricians next I think
the concern in health healthare is just
the ability to work with a patient
one-on-one so um what the boards are
looking for when they see these
applications is it's more serious
offenses of you know physical assault um
sexual assault those sorts of things um
so every board that has a criminal
record check we're working on putting
together what's called a matrix so that
if someone has a minor conviction um
that's never going to make it to the
board's desk those people get licensed
up follow up thank you so if I had
a criminal background and uh because of
theft or whatever and it was whatever is
I put I went to jail and they had my
fingerprints and all that what I
probably wouldn't be able to get a
license I mean to me it's just
governments we're just putting we're
becoming a nanny State I mean doesn't
make sense what we need this criminal
background I'm okay with everything else
but the criminal background is there any
way that you feel comfortable without
that part in
there so I I want to clarify a little
bit so the process that the legislature
has put in place for a review of a
criminal record check and whether it um
disqualifies you from becoming a lensey
under a board is RSA 332 gon 10 that
sets up a burden of proof of clearing
convin ing evidence that's on the state
so it's a very very high standard for um
I I I should probably preface with this
I've been the hearings examiner before I
took over this position of general
counsel um with the office of
professional licenser and certification
for since October of 2021 I've done a
lot of these hearings there are very few
very very few where someone walks away
without a license and um of those
hearings right the majority of people
that are applying or not even going to a
hearing so um the legislature I think
has set up a fair
statute um that protects the
public but also ensures that we're
licensed one more followup
representative thank you I I was just
going to say so has the public come to
you saying we need criminal background
checks on these licensers because they
feel
safe I've only been in this position for
a few months so I can't answer that that
question really well but in my few
months that I've been here no would be
the answer yep y um representative um
one of the areas is people assume
certain people are background checked
like people assume Library volunteers
are even though they aren't um so it's
just a matter of standardization so
that's something that I think we can
discuss as a committee as well later on
representative de Madam sherff thank you
um would it be fair fair to say that
under this Matrix somebody who was um
convicted of a sexual assault then would
probably not meet the licensing
requirements and therefore not have
access to one-on-one patient care
including with minors this is that
something that this that would be
checked that the criminal background
check would would address right so the
the background check would address that
um and I just want to be clear
too internally we are not denying people
just because they have a conviction they
get hearing I get a hearing under RSA
332 G and 10 with that same burden of
proof that I was talking about that is
placed on the
state followup thank you um so it would
trigger if you found something like that
on a criminal background check it would
then trigger hearing yes correct thank
you very much
yep um and I will ask a question on this
as well I know in some other areas we
have um especially in teacher licensing
we spell out specifically which
convictions are qualifying uh my
question would be if um it's just more
of an issue where where right now the
hearings officers are working through
and they have a good way of
understanding the difference between a
decent exposure because somebody thought
a Bush was in the way when they couldn't
make it inside versus an indecent
exposure that is far more indecent and
is it some of that discretion on the
part of the hearing officers to
understand the true nature of the
conviction so yeah so the board is the
FactFinder it's similar to how our
disciplinary hearings works so the board
is the FactFinder uh the presiding
officer the hearings examiner is the
basically makes the legal decisions so
um the hearings are set up to hear the
facts of the case the specific facts of
the case to determine whether um the
conviction is such that it should
disqualify the person for public
protection
reasons thank you any other questions
from the committee saying none thank you
very much okay thank you very much
is there anybody else here to speak on
House Bill
214 seeing none I will close this
hearing
all right I'll open the hearing on House
land thank you madam chair House Bill
227 is one of those bills that I think
should be pretty simple however that's
why we're having a hearing and having a
chance to discuss it right now there are
two different school psychologist uh
Psychotherapy licenses and the
Department of Education is also enabled
to create other licensing for
Psychotherapy in the schools uh to me
it's that would seem to relieve any need
that they would have for licensing
within the schools so you would not need
an exemption for anybody who is employed
by a state County Municipal agency or
other political subdivision or a duly
chartered educational
institution so the the idea of having
people who are not licensed to practice
Psychotherapy permitted to do so without
a license in our schools is quite
troubling uh we have many we have
resources in our schools perhaps not as
many as we would like but when you're
speaking about a vulnerable child it's
even more important to make sure that
there are appropriate standards for
those who are offering these Services um
I also want to note that there is
another exemption for the Psychotherapy
licensing and that's when you're working
for some sort of company or nonprofit
that takes on the financial ethical or
moral responsibility for you because you
are not
licensed there is only the broad
responsibility of that of local
government or the educational
institution because ultimately if the
government does somebody wrong uh we the
taxpayers are on the hook for that
problem allowing private in institutions
to take that responsibility allows them
to take that risk however state
government already has a fantastic way
to ensure that only those people with
appropriate training and knowledge can
participate in licensed activities like
Psychotherapy and so wavering waving
that without um such waving that just
seems to be a bit too far we already
have our processes we already have our
standards and I believe that it is in
the Public's interest to remove this
exemption to licensing so we can ensure
that everybody who's practicing
Psychotherapy um is is doing so with
appropriate care with that I'm happy to
take
questions representative
Roa thank you representative Leon so on
the um on the exception from did you say
that the Department of Education had
standards and could issue a license for
a school psychotherapist or did I
misunderstand what you were saying um
thank you for the question there are two
different classifications of school
psych psychotherapists and r a 329b 329b
also gives the Department of Education
the ability to create another
necessary followup follow up and this
bill eliminates that option no this bill
does not touch that department of op of
Education process for additional lure um
what this bill does is it removes a full
and complete um exemption from licensing
for Psychotherapy Services at these
instit institions
so um what this means is most of what
people are held to for Psychotherapy is
done through the licensing if you look
um the conversion therapy ban is fully
en enforced through licensing statutes
so if you're not licensed there's
nothing that stops you from doing
potentially horrible things to people um
with with this you could have a teacher
who's not licensed for
Psychotherapy doing things that we have
deemed completely inappropriate with no
real way of addressing that because
that's not anywhere in the teachers um
in the teacher's contract or the
teachers's requirements because normally
that type of thing which should never
happen would happen in in a in something
Psychotherapy representative Pearson um
I have a I have a question for you
considering the nature in which the
topic of this
covers other committees that we have in
the house is this a two Bill committee
or a two bill or a two committee Bill
rather let me look it up and get back to
you on it I think not it was not when I
reviewed it earlier okay thank you sure
all right probably not
I second one uh I'm just I'm kind of
like dealing with a little bit of
internal shock right now that we're even
having to that this even exists um wow
looking
at State County Municipal agency or
other political subdivision or or duly
chartered educational
institution can you help me out on what
duly chartered educational institution
covers thank you that's a great question
and is one of the problems of having our
laws be built upon each other as as
opposed to going and looking more
holistically about everything that's
impacted by each of these bills that we
deal with when I was looking and trying
to trace through the breadcrumbs of all
the changes to the statute um I I I
don't know how many years I went back
trying to find when this was actually
inserted in the law but it's old and
many many many parts of our protective
statutes for Psychotherapy have changed
and been added to and created since the
time that this exemption was put in
place I think at one time it served a
purpose but I think at this point it is
old and Antiquated and uh should be put
pasture
okay other
questions representative sellers thank
you madam chair so on that note as well
is I'm I'm just making sure this is not
going
schools um thank you for that question
I'm not sure it says duly chartered
educational institution um I would have
a hard
time if if this the only way that this
wouldn't impact the private schools
would be if they weren't allowed to have
unlicensed people practicing
Psychotherapy today if um if a private
school is included in this then it would
separate them from this and mean that
they need to be licensed um if they're
not then they can't do that anyways
there is a separate um exemption for
clergy and for other groups where
where there there's other exemptions I'm
not removing all the exemptions from the
law um but what I'm focusing on is State
County municipal or political
subdivisions or the educational
institutions because I think our law is
evolved to become a lot richer and this
is
Antiquated yeah it depends on whether a
private school falls under a uh
chartered educational Institution
yes follow follow up thank you mam chair
I'm just I'm getting hung up with these
three words ched education institutions
does that cover our Public
Schools I'm just I I
just yeah that's my my understanding is
that that would cover our private our
public schools because they are they're
also a political subdivision because our
school districts are political
subdivisions
Schmid is just going to go to a
subcommittee well I was hoping it
wouldn't be necessary well the thing is
because we have the sponsor do we have
any other pink cards of people who are
going to speak to us about this issue
there
is
uh Mr Fry from the oplc is available for
questions because I think this is kind
of a drop dead Bill uh and uh so to the
degree that we don't have any uh
any anyone who's in practitioner of
these activities uh or oversees them or
whatever I think we're standing on the
diving board in the night wondering
whether there's any water in the pool
before we dive
off may I answer that question please um
we're actually speaking about people who
are not overseeing by anybody there is
absolutely no oversight of people who
are Exempted from the licensing statutes
so you have people who legally are
allowed to practice medicine without a
license and this is removing that
exemption so that they would have to be
overseen I I I understand the the
premise of the bill uh but I just would
like to have a a little bit more of a he
said she said uh treatment of the matter
I I I understand that it's like a trapo
you don't see um but I abide by whatever
thinks apparently the psych
psychological committee or the
psychologist Comm Community didn't think
this was important enough to to register
because we've dealt with them before and
they are very they feel no no difficulty
in jumping in and letting us know if
there is an
issue and Madam chair they are aware of
this bill because they spoke to me about
it and they said that they had no
problem with that because they the I'm
not saying that this is an official
statement but the message that I
received was that they had no problem
with this because they believed that
people should be licensed in order to
practice
Psychotherapy and it didn't raise to
enough of a bar for them to come to this
hearing okay thank you that's good to
know right see what do they got
there
exemptions I'll set this stuff here yeah
there's specific definition of what a
school psychologist and either at the
doctoral or the specialist level in
statute and in rules there's a
so so it said it unlawful for any person
to do this except unless they are
licensed or under the direct supervision
of a
lensey so that's there
and so I think that
the the question is whether your county
jail can emplo can employ someone to uh
perform Psychotherapy on the inmates
without without a license and apparently
this is sure no
problem I I think so and the question is
whether inmates also deserve that same
right of same standard to have licensed
professionals represent
Bailey all of this being said I kind of
begin to wonder about the fiscal note if
there are people out there in the world
pring practicing psychology or without a
license and now we're going to take away
that exemption and require it are we
going to have to be hiring certified
psychologists it is wouldn't that be
more expensive than uncertified people
who are doing it
now well uh representative Pearson wants
to jump in on my question to that would
be what how expensive is one massive
lawsuit I mean we're looking at a no no
I'm not $350 million lawsuit right now
out of the cunu center so I'm not
questioning that I guess I'm questioning
that it's going to be less than 10 grand
for the next 3 years and not if you have
to hire a whole bunch of people that are
certified now I believe although this is
purely my judgment they're saying we
don't know of anybody who's actually
doing this if there's just a couple it's
one or two licensing fees which are
which will be used by the
oplc and and I didn't mean to question
the the benefit of this just that the
fiscal note doesn't seem to make sense
oh well I I'm sure that they primarily
considered licensing fees and not the uh
the effect of of say your county jail
having a $20,000 a year person doing
Psychotherapy and then they'd have to
you see who they talk
to yes repr grto okay you so I'm reading
section two of um the
RSA and you
um want to eliminate section one you
want to repeal one and why not
two because this says that the
Department of
Education can credential individuals
with the title certified school
psychologist but a psychologist and a
psychotherapist are not the same thing
so why why would you not wipe out the
whole
thing I think that's a good point I
think that we first want to look at
having people who are completely
unsupervised and completely
unaccountable to anybody um I I think
that that may actually go to some of the
cost issue um I don't know if I I didn't
look to see if anybody was licensed
under those statutes from the Department
of Education because I wasn't looking to
impact those I was just looking to
impact the looking to address the
completely unlicensed practice of
medicine um that and I'd be happy to
look into that one and see if we should
do that next year in order to remove
that from the Department of Education
whether that would be correct or
not followup I think it's something that
we can check for this year I don't see
why we can't talk about this in
subcommittee if we if it goes to
subcommittee because I think that's an
important
Point thank you I'll reach out to the
Department of Education and get
information from
them
okay my only my only fear in that is
that if we if we go that one more
paragraph is that that paragraph the
purview of the education committe and
not Edna I mean are we crossing crossing
crafts here in essence are we you know
what I mean is is that going to start to
make that a two committee bill in
essence that's just my only fear with
that is
and I think that's a really good point
we don't want other committees doing
Edna's
work um I believe that
title yeah that's
interesting um I think it does need a a
little bit of of checking to see um um
what what they're doing but I did notice
further up there's a
definition uh in
b15a of what a licensed school
psychologist has the
requirements so um I think that to to to
look into whether that covers all the
people that the Department of Education
will credential or
not uh would be
worthwhile sorry about that I think it's
going to go a subcommittee I'm I
apologize no just just so I understand
since I know where this is going
um instead instead of taking the
exemption route changing the definition
route to cover this instead that would
be legitimate um we just don't
want the purpose is not to explicitly
allow local governments to hire
unqualified individuals sure okay and my
understanding was that the Department of
Education would be additive to repealing
this section not replacing repealing
this section okay well all right well we
we will let this go to
subcommittee any further questions or
issues to be brought
up okay I don't see any thank you
representative thank you is there anyone
else who wishes to speak on House Bill
227 actually Mr Fry you have answers to
you how was it off there we
go um so the fiscal note question when
we wrote that fiscal note we based it
off the instructions for the fiscal note
worksheet which was to base it off of
what is the impact on OPC so that's why
as um representative Maguire was saying
it was really more we were focused on
what is the impact on
licensing um so yes they also asked the
Department of Corrections and health and
human services so apparently it's not a
venues there any other questions I can
answer I don't see any but thank you for
for that information all right thank
you anyone else wish to testify
all right seeing none I will close the
hearing
and right on schedule open the hearing
on House Bill 236 and call
Representative
buns thank you madam chairwoman and uh
good afternoon members of the committee
it's my pleasure to be here today with
you to introduce uh House Bill
236 for the record my name is Chris muns
I am one of the four state
representatives along with h
representative def from Rockingham
District 29 representing the town of
Hampton when I was in business school
accounting was not one of the
disciplines I shall we say uh easily
embraced um I spent many Saturday
mornings and supplemental classes
offered to me and the few others of my
classmates who were clearly not getting
it that's why when I told some of my
classmates at our fifth reunion that I
was the uh Financial controller of a
business unit they were
shocked um it's also why I have the
utmost respect for anyone who invested
the time and effort to become a
certified public
accountant to become a CPA in New
Hampshire today you must earn a
bachelor's degree or higher with 150
semester hours from an accredited
college or
university complete 30 semester hours of
accounting courses including Financial
Accounting management accounting
auditing and Taxation complete 24
semester hours of business courses pass
the uniform CPA exam have no felony
record gain at least one year of
full-time experience in accounting Andor
audit skills and apply for and obtain it
at a cost of at least $150 a license to
practice in the state that license must
now be renewed every 2 years and to do
so a CPA must complete 40 hours of
approved continuing professional
education courses per year and a minimum
of four hours of Ethics training for
each renewal period so in other words
someone who is currently a
CPA put in a great deal of time effort
and money to pursue that career path and
they should be justifiably proud of the
accomplish M and the fact that they can
include the title CPA after their
name but then once they retire and their
license laps lapses they are no longer
allowed to include that title after
their
name HB 236 permits the office of
professional liur and certification to
Grant an individual who has retired and
previously held a certificate as a
certified public accountant the
honorific title of CPA
retired any individual who has granted
that title may use it on a business card
letter head email signature line or any
other document or device but they may
not use it to represent themselves or
allow themselves to be represented as a
current practicing
CPA they may not also perform or offer
to perform services for which a license
certificate or permit may be required
under state law
not only is this a relatively simple way
to recognize a lifetime's worth of work
by these dedicated professionals it
permits them to let organizations they
may want to
volunteer know that they have a
particular skill that might be of
significant benefit to those
organizations someone with the title CPA
retired for example will not be able to
complete and sign off on the audited
financials for their local food pantry
or family animal shelter but they could
certainly help those nonprofits organize
and Report their financial results and
knowing that a CPA retired is helping to
oversee their finances that could very
well help those organizations in their
fundraising
efforts this bill was requested by the
board of accountancy and it has been
reviewed by the office of professional
liur and
certification well I cannot say whether
opic supports the bill they certainly
did not have any issues with the way it
is
worded I urge you to recommend this bill
is ought to pass to our colleagues in
the house and I'm happy to try to answer
any questions that you may have but as I
mentioned accounting is not necessarily
my thing and I believe there are some
real accountants here who who can answer
any detailed questions that you may have
thank
you are there questions representative
Pearson
let me give you the hypothetical
that that you kind of just
explained so you
retire right I'm a licensed empt I
retire from the fire
service if you were to have a business
card or if you were to to put simply
that you are a CPA retired what law
would you violate
in just
listing such a
thing in other words is that isti 309
b14 I think it's Roman 2 oh no Roman
three no person not holding a valid
certificate or practice privilege shall
use or assume the title or designation
certified public account or the
abbreviation CPA or any other title Etc
tending to indicate that such person is
a CPA sure so but if you put CPA retired
on a business card have you violated the
law I believe the accountants are
concerned that they it might be so
considered so I the that's that's why
this what this bill would do is a was
create a new section in that RSA that
specifically allows someone to um have a
um have the CPA retired
status I will say that that looking at
that section there's about a page and a
half of restrictions on the use of the
title so it's it's fairly extensive that
you can't call your yourself various
accounting type things without a license
and
I'm I'm not sure what the uh the whether
this whole new title is exactly
necessary but uh representa of cite well
I'm prepared to vote for this violation
of the First Amendment it's the truth
you're a retired CPA and it no our state
that thank you any other questions
comments all right I don't see anyone
and
comments no specific comments just to
say we don't take any position on the
bill okay anyone else wish to testify
yes
please what's that repres me
representative lean has a question uh
thank you madam chairman and um thank
you would there be a cost to um doing
this retired status certification yeah
so in the we when we put together the
fiscal note worksheet for this we um
presumed a one-time
cost and would you um as a followup
would you need to have any authorization
to charge a fee for that one-time cost I
don't believe so we I pedal back and
forth with this with someone at the
legislative office and I cited RSA
3104 or six I can't remember which of
the two statutes but it's our fee
statute and it gives us the authority to
um do administrative fees thank
you we're going to be making any other
changes I would recommend we explicitly
authorize the fee because that's it may
not be 100% necessary but it's certainly
recommended thank you that would be
appreciated all right uh Richard uh
uh I'd like to thank first of all uh
representative muns and senator alcha
for sponsoring the bill and providing
and and representative providing some
excellent background on surrounding this
bill I would like to provide some
further elaboration concerning the bill
that may help you in your
determination my name is Richard
Silverman I have been an actively
licensed CPA in New Hampshire for 49
years I currently serve on the New
Hampshire Board of accountants
accountancy and was the previous
chairman I also have served on the board
of National Association of uh Boards of
accountancy also known as
nasba I come before you to ask your
support for HR 236
a bill to allow a CPA to use a honorific
title retired
CPA the license the CPA license allows
the licy to provide auditing and attest
services in app Pine and sign financial
statements currently when a CPA no
longer wishes to provide these Services
there are two choices either apply for
inactive status or let their license
expire in
2018 CPA's retired status was adopted by
the uniform accounting act the uniform
accounting Act is an evergreen model act
designed to achieve several objectives
as the name suggests the ACT provides
the goal of
uniformity in addition the ACT provides
public
protection and promotes High ethical and
Professional Standards it's a
collaboration of nasba the national
associ is and board of accountancy in
the American Institute of CPAs which is
a Trade Organization for
CPAs currently 22 states have adopted
the retired status with others it is
under consideration for those states
that have adopted the status many CPAs
have applied and been granted this
status as it appears in the uniform
accounting act the CPAs who are at least
55 years of age May Place their license
in retired status and not continue with
certified continuing professional
education requirements for those CPAs at
the end of their career this provision
offers an
exception to ensure that they can
continue offer a limited number of
volunteer uncompensated services to the
public but cannot provide accounting I'm
sorry auditing and ATT test
Services nothing in this statute should
preclude a retired CP a at least 55
years of age from providing volunteer or
uncompensated Services tax preparation
Services participating in a government
sponsored business mentoring program
serving on the board of directors of a
nonprofit or governmental organization
or serving on a government appointed
Advisory Board licenses may only convert
to CPA status if they have held or hold
a license in good standing with the
state of New Hampshire I would
appreciate your support on this
important bill and welcome any questions
you might have representative
Schmidt thank you madam chair thank you
for being here you're the lone
stranger to begin with and I hope we
will look and see if there's anybody
online watching the hearing but uh you
already spoke to the initial question I
had uh with regard to what other states
uh may have done or be doing um are you
aware whether of how long this uh
concept has been in in uh existence in
other states and what kind of a re re
result or reaction it's had well I uh
like I said in since 2018 it became part
of the uniform accountancy act so that's
when states started to adopt it um and I
know from talking to one other chairman
who of one of the other uh boards state
boards that within the last two years
has passed it they had a significant
amount of CPAs who were in this inactive
or expired status apply for it and were
granted it so it has been popular in the
states that have accepted it well I just
will say that uh followup
that um as a regular user of CPA
Services over number of years I
recognize the tremendous expertise that
you have to have to do the job and you
have to have nerves of Steel uh to be
willing to take
on I haven't brought in a box shoe box
full of but I know it's a common
phenomenon that you have to Wade through
so and your question Lu would you
believe that
yes are there any questions
representative
Pearson what
happens so you know the status you have
to be you know you had had to be a CPA
had to make 55 years of age and all that
what happens if you enter into the
retired status and decide you want to go
back next to being a CPA and you don't
want to necessarily be retired anymore
what what happens then you can
reapply and you have to present evidence
of continuing professional
education uh under the current
requirements of granting a license so
for there is a section of the statute on
reinstate licensed
reinstatement and coming back from
retirement would would would qualify
right because currently some CPAs are in
the category I discussed earlier which
is the inactive status and there is a a
a provision for them to come back and
that would apply to retired CPAs as well
so they would be treated as
inactive
okay well actually they're more
restricted inactive can
do
um they can't there's a few there's some
other things inactive CPAs can do no no
okay well then why don't we just let
them why don't we just retitle the
inactive to
retired uh the inactive is really there
so people who want to come back into the
profession for some reason have gone
into industry don't want to do the
current CPE have done it retired is more
for people like myself that want to
serve on boards and serve the public and
don't have any desire to to work
anymore thank
you all right any other
questions all right thank you very much
for your testimony thank you very much
is there is there anyone else who wishes
236 all right seeing none I'll close the
public
hearing do we have anybody mam chair do
we have anybody online who's been
watching the
hearing I don't think we can see that
we can't tell as far as I know
representative representative Pearson do
you think we should uh go into executive
this okay let's go into executive
session on House Bill 236 does someone
motion I'm I'm getting a hay eyeball
from Jackie so sure I'll make the motion
to AUD pass
236 all right representative Pearson
moves on to pass I'll second that
second ah sellers all
right do you wish to speak to your
motion sure the um I think it was well
explained the questions were
answered
I had no idea that CPAs were very
specifically restricted in the way they
could identify themselves retired which
I I agree with representative scitec in
the in the sense that H how is this even
a thing so um this seems like uh there's
no risk to the public here it's not a I
don't think it's deceptive in any way so
uh I I see no issue with it thank you
representative zers you wish to speak to
your second I was going to say yes thank
titles okay uh that's very true
represent groda
so if we pass this there's nothing in
here that that tells that says that they
have to that oplc can charge a
fee and I'm first of all I'm sort of on
the fence on this bill
because I can't think of any other
profession where you can't use your
title and say you're retired so I don't
know
why I mean the CPA organ board may not
like it but so what I'm trying
to you know can I throw a 180 at you
representative gr you can throw me
whatever you want okay so with all the
other professions there's no restriction
to say that you are
retired necessarily
like why here why why this one
specifically being prohibitive in
statute I when I retire from the fire
service it doesn't say that they can't
say that but it does it there are a lot
of res a lot of explicit restrictions on
calling yourself a CPA it's not clear
that calling yourself a retired CPA
law from what I understand what what
representative what the chair is saying
and I remember when we went through all
the CPA stuff there is nothing that says
they can't say CPA retired it's not in
statute they're assuming that because
the other requirements are so
stringent so did they you know did the
board box itself in and is there I'm
just asking the question because I mean
in essence if they are not if there's
really no explicit restriction for their
for them to use the title then there's
really no reason for the oplc to have to
charge anything to do
anything they this just kind of I guess
makes it where we're kind of saying hey
you can do it and don't worry about it
if you know what I mean because if it's
illegal yes exactly represent Leon uh
thank you madam chairman uh previous to
this my understanding around the use of
CPA was almost like they had trademarked
it because they had Pro built so many
protections around the use of that term
and now they had built up those
protections so much that now there's a
concern about using it to me I see the
two pass of if you created that much and
you want to have a new regulatory path
for a retired certification we should
make sure that we're charging the
administrative fee for the time that it
takes from oplc or perhaps look to the
language that says that you can't use it
um and say and add to those exemptions
for using the title CPA unless you've
retired in good standing um unless
you've unless when you stopped
practicing you were in good standing and
have not done it separately I recognize
the value of having the model
legislation across the state so that
there's consistency but in that case I'd
want to make ensure that we're able to
charge that fee for the time for
OPC represent s suppose oplc does
nothing and we just print the cards and
the law authorizes
it I'm that works for me representative
Pearson well I I guess it just boils
down
to are we is this just enabling in the
sense of allowing the use of the term or
are we now
taking it a step further and saying that
the office of the oplc is going to have
some sort of a list or a tracking or a
database where someone would hence
verify that someone's retired as a CPA
you see what I'm saying yes I understand
if we're just saying it's not illegal
that's one
thing but this so I can can we can we
have the sponsor come up and maybe ask
him what the intention here is then is
to what they're looking for
or
someone I ask could I ask Mr Silverman
to join me
sure the the question is are you
intending to have the oplc keep records
of this or is it just something that Mr
Silverman could put on his card or when
he's on the board of a the local food
bank or whatever um go ahead currently
the oplc does keep records of all of us
as to our status whether it's expired
our license is expired whether we've
asked for inactive status or we are
currently renewed so they're already
keeping track of what we do it would be
just another category they would have so
we would submit an uh an application to
be
retired somebody at LP would check that
we have been or are currently in good
standing
and that
would allow us to enter the retired
category representative Pearson then
that was that's going to have a cost to
it if that's what they want I don't I
don't see a problem with a minimal
one-time cost for getting it because
somebody does has to have to look it up
I don't you know renew your license is a
lot more detailed because they have to
check for your continuing professional
education requirements this basically is
to check the database to see if you're
in good
standing and you know what your current
status is so I I don't have a problem
with that at all okay so Madam chair the
question is then is this going to be
something that's handled through rules
or do we or are we going to explicitly
outline what the fee for this status
will be in
statute since oplc has the authority to
do that representative sellers thank you
m chair so on on line um
15 it says that they um they sh they
shall Grant a
certificate stating that they're retired
so op PLC at least has got to do one
step see that they were working and had
a license and now they're
retired so it doesn't seem like an awful
oplc okay M Madam Madam chairman
ask representative M you um I I guess in
in you know um with regard to you know
do you include the specifics of a fee in
the bill or not I mean and maybe oplc
can answer this I don't know what is I
don't know if there is a specific fee in
legislation right now for somebody
applying to be a CPA or whether that's
something that they just do through
their rules process it I I think follow
it's been in both both places uh I think
it's in rules at the
moment intended to cover the
costc
set all right any further comments
questions all right I'm I think I'm with
representative scitec and I don't not
sure this is entirely necessary but uh
if the CPAs have wrapped their titles in
it's anyone else comments questions
issues
represent I just want to be
clear
that if we don't collect fee for
this which it doesn't say that we're
going to do that then that means they
get their certificate and that's the end
of the deal they're cut loose and they
do what they want and if I mean they put
CPA retired and if somebody who is in a
CPA and put CPA
retired then what I mean what does that
mean nothing right and basically means
it's a nothing
thing and who who is to enforce this
right that's you know am I making this
too complicated I just want to
understand I we're going through the
same me when we talk about licensing and
we talk about these kinds of things we
have hearty discussions about them
because they're important things they
something I I mean I like I said I have
if if the office of oplc is going to
have to maintain a database and they're
going to have to process this that is an
incor cost yes no question so I I don't
necessarily have a problem that under
the current method in which they're
operating and that they'll figure out
the very minuscule amount of work that
this does take and aign a value to that
that's fine and I do agree with you
representative Grotto that it is not
outlined in here and that would require
amendment to put that in there and I
don't necessarily have a problem with
that either it's just like I said we
were just you know just trying to figure
out what exactly they're going for here
and make make that match
this repres so This leans to then
legislative intent so I just want Mr
Silverman to understand that right now
all we're saying is there's going to be
a list someplace that's going to have
your name checked off as retired and
that's
it there's going to be no database
management of who's following the
retirement law and who isn't
does you that is that clear to
you it's like anything else that comes
before the board if somebody violate
something and somebody files a complaint
it would come before the board and then
the board would have to address that
complaint just like if you know if a CPA
violated a provision and come and you
filed a complaint against that CPA board
meets and makes a determination with the
office of enforcement it would be the
exact same
thing and the only violation I could see
is if they
were practicing things that they were
not allowed to practice for instance
certifying financial statements signing
and aining on financial statements or if
a
bookkeeper with who had never been a CPA
decided to put CPA retired on his
business card that would cause the oplc
to enforce it if someone complained we
would send that directly to
enforcement thank
you any other comments representative
land um thank you madam chair uh looking
at this stat the section 309b um this
would fall under all the other
rulemaking authority um so I I think
that I was may have been jumping the gun
thinking we need to specifically add the
ability to charge the fee into this I
just wanted to make sure we weren't
causing a problem but if we whenever we
write this up if we make it clear that
we intend for them to be charged an
appropriate fee in the blur that would
probably be helpful
okay anyone else all right that case I
think we should wrap this up in that
case I'm going to have to withdraw then
the the autop pass motion if this needs
to be amended no no she's saying it
doesn't need to be it doesn't need to be
amended because it's already covered
yeah gotcha and what I'm saying is that
you're right that it's our expectation
that they would do it it's minor so it
would only be a minor minor fee to issue
this
okay the motion is ought to pass by
representative Pearson and the clerk can
role Vice chairman Leon yes clerk votes
yes representative Pearson yes
representative Bailey yes what happened
to
I uh representative sellers
yes
representative Gro
yes representative Schmidt yes
representative Davis yes representative
Dary
yes representative Howard
yes representative stes
chair no I still don't think it's
necessary you're going to vote no okay
um
111 do you uh okay the motion passes 11
to one I will not be writing a Minority
Report are you okay with consent I
that's what I was going to ask does
anyone object to
consent okay we'll put it on consent
representative Pearson a committee
all right in that case we're coming out
of executive session and I'm opening
the you let a few more people bring in
cards if you're a representative you're
towards the
top
that's thank
you that's fine all right thank you I've
um I'm calling representative peternell
as one of the sponsors in place of the
sick good afternoon Madame chairwoman
and members of the committee um for the
record my name is Katie Pell and I
represent um Carol district 6 the towns
of wolfboro and Tuftonboro I'm here
today I'm a co-sponsor on this bill but
I am um introducing the bill for
representative kofalt who could not be
here today and I just received his
testimony an hour ago so I can't
necessarily answer a lot of technical
questions about this bill but I'm more
than happy to be a supporter of it uh HB
349 expands the scope of practice for
licensed optometrist to perform three
specific opth Opthalmic laser procedures
provided that the practitioner is first
certified by the board of registration
in
Optometry so this bill um is similar to
last year's Senate Bill 440 which passed
the Senate on a Voice vote and came out
of this committee with a 14-6
recommendation of ought to pass so while
SB 440 expanded the scope of practice
for optomet interest in a number of ways
HB 349 is far more limited and would
simply allow for these three specific
procedures for which most many
optometrists are trained but not
currently authorized to perform in New
Hampshire and this is something that I
did not know until I got received this
testimony but Optometry is the only
profession for which permitted
procedures are Del delineated within
State Statute while that seems
problematic this bill does not aim to
address the broader problem of uh
allowing them to
um uh
sorry
um to manage their own um practice scope
of practice in this case the focus is on
these three specific um procedures those
three procedures are laser capsulotomy
which is a procedure that treats
complications after cataract surgery
laser tacul plasty and Laser peripheral
iridotomy and those are both
treatments um House Bill 349 also
authorizes the board of registration and
Optometry to adopt certification
criteria so they will have they would
require minimum education training and
hands-on experience criteria for
proctoring so that somebody of an
optometrist isn't um just let loose on
their own to practice they need to be
trained with somebody following them and
outcome reporting um requirements
there's also a significant investment
for these um machines a minimum of
$75,000 I know our local optometrist
said that they might cost a minimum of
$100,000 So based on that it would be my
personal assumption that no one was
taking this investment
lightly and they also I've also been
told that this is primarily in order to
be able to provide a service to their to
their patients something that they have
trouble
accessing um so in that in comes to the
access to care rural areas face
significant shortages of opthalmologists
um and the number of opthalmologists is
also
declining however the number of
optometrists is increasing and I happen
to live in Carrol County where we have
only one opthalmologist in the entire
area and I have some letters from
patients who've had to travel long
distances in order to receive some of
these therapies and I was given
information that the closest um
opthalmologist to my town is 30 minutes
away but when I um put that into um
Google Maps it's 43 minutes from my
house and I happen to know that it's
over a lot of twisty windy roads that
are difficult for people um who have
trouble seeing especially if their
appointment were in the evening which
happens easily in the winter because
4:00 comes pretty
quickly um so you have to be really
careful about when you're scheduling
your your
appointments um also average weight
times for these procedures in an
opthalmologist office range from um well
3.6 to 4
months um um patients undergoing eye
procedures are often unable to drive to
or from their appointments which
requires them to find someone to go with
them taking up considerable time for a
caregiver um this bill would reduce
weight times and travel burdens for
patients um patients in Southern New
Hampshire Express similar concerns that
current New Hampshire laws leads to Long
waiting times and delayed treatment
while they're waiting their quality of
life suffers it's imagine if you have
trouble seeing that impacts your quality
of life um this also would reduce health
care costs because the increased
availability of care typically leads to
lower health care costs patients have
more options they can choose where they
want to be
treated um as for some issues that might
come up particularly patient safety
there are 12 states that currently allow
optometrist to perform these procedures
um optometrist in Kentucky Oklahoma and
Louisiana have safely performed these
procedures for well over a decade and
Oklahoma has allowed these procedures
since
1998 an evidence indicates Adverse
Events in just two cases out of over
0.1% um but to as a comparison the
average American's odds of dying in a
car accident in any given year are 0
one% so about 10 times higher than the
odds of suffering adverse effects from
one of these procedures if performed by
an
optometrist so we don't actually know
whether op opthalmologists have a
similar rate of adverse effects with
these procedures so we don't know if
that's um potentially higher or lower
than what optometrist experience we were
unable to find data on that but
presumably that number is not zero and
it could very well be the same as the
rate experienced by
optometrists insurance carriers who
specialize in medical malpractice
meanwhile recognize that the
quantifiable risk of expanded scope of
practice is
negligible this is reflected in
virtually flat premiums for malpractice
insurance for
optometrists if this bill becomes law
patient safety will be safeguarded by
stringent certification processes
established by the board though I urge
you to support House Bill 349 so that
New Hampshire residents can have access
to the care that they
need thank you for the committee we have
a large stack of professionals who are
going to be speaking to us on this bill
so please don't ask technical questions
of the
representatives representative
Schmidt thank you madam chair thank you
for being here Katie so how soon do you
think uh the this entire new uh area of
practice could be available in the state
of New Hampshire oh that's a very good
question well first we do have some
optometrists who are trained but I don't
know what process they would have to go
through obviously we would have to this
would have to go through rules so that's
issue number one so that that's what six
months minimum after the passage of a
bill usually typically um and then
optometrist have to invest in the
machines they have to be trained if
they're not currently trained it could
be a little while I'm sure a year or two
at minimum I would imagine and that's
I'm purely speculation on my part thank
you representative Howard thank you for
taking my question uh so just to clarify
I mean you just said that some
optometrists uh have the uh the the
training to do this uh do they go
through that training in school I
actually don't know the answer to that
question I'm sure some of the
optometrist here would would be able to
answer that
okay thank you yeah other
questions thank you very much thank you
representative
Greg thank you Madame chairwoman and
committee I'm Alicia Greg I am lucky
enough to represent NASA one of the 27
from there I'm here to talk surprisingly
about Optometry today besides having
eyes I haven't always had a lot of
experience in this besides when I had to
go to the eye doctor myself and I find
it fascinating that this is something in
the legislature but it is I've had many
constituents call me wanting to look at
this particularly upset about what
happened last year because of the lack
of care one thing I can do is a lot of
research so I started looking into it it
was no surprise to me that this is not
something unusual within the medical
community I've had experience in this my
late husband was a nurse and athetist
the Dynamics that you find between
anesthetist anesthesiologist and
anesthesia texts is very very similar
there are a lot of parts in the medical
community where you have multiple people
doing different things and it can raise
alarms so I looked at this to think well
how how does this make difference
because I do know that in when um I'm
going to switch up the optomologist and
optometrist here but optometrists when
they go to school they're actually
require required to have this train
training what we are asking them to be
able to do today in 349 is to be able to
lasers that they're actually already
trained to do it's required in their
schooling this isn't something they take
as an option it's part of their
schooling so they're already they're
already trained for that so you look at
why why would we not let them do that
well there's always a push and pull
within the medical community I'm sure
many of you at this point have seen a
nurse practitioner when nurse
practitioners first began Physicians
were all up in arm there were quite a
few of them that testified that there
would be a lack of care or that there
would be more malpractice or patience
wouldn't be as safe I fell into that I
thought you know what if I'm paying the
same co-pay or the same amount I'd
rather see a physician that was until
one time I needed to get into a doctor
and I had a six-month waiting period but
I could get into the nurse practitioner
the next day and it's amazing I now have
a primary nurse practitioner because I
have that confidence they do have the
training to be able to do that I don't
find this any different they're already
trained to do this it's there however
there is a push of news propaganda
whatever else saying that this could be
dangerous a lot of Scare Tactics also
not unusual when you find one medical
Branch or one specialty starting to
Branch out into more things um
anesthesia was the same way Believe It
or Not nurs anesthetists were around
before
anesthesiologists and anesthesiologist
figured out oh there's a lot of money in
that and they took it back and then when
a nurse and athetist started performing
again because it was more costeffective
you add another push and pull now
Dynamics are not something that we
handle here that's for them to figure
out what we handle is our constituents
we know that the the number of
opthalmologists are declining we know
and I can tell by everybody that has
glasses in here that the number of
patients is not declining so then we
have to look at what's best for our
constituents I went back and I looked
not at news reports or anything else but
at hard facts within the legal system
about what does it look like for
malpractice suits because there are
places um like my colleague just said
talked about that they have been
performing these particular procedures
so I wanted to say has malpractice gone
up in these in these states the answer
is no it actually hasn't gone up at all
as a matter of fact then I looked at
well what is the malpractice because
maybe there's more malpractice for these
jections versus normal things no that
hasn't changed either the most common
malpractice for opthalmologists and
optometrist both is lack of
diagnosis so this is something that we
can provide to our
constituency the ability to have care
just like you can go see a nurse
practitioner if you don't want to wait
six months to get in a doctor and I'll
tell you one time I had an ulcer in the
middle of my cornea and there is nothing
more painful I'm pretty sure on Earth so
I know how sens ensi we are about our
eyes and you need to get into somebody
right away we're talking about
injections that do glaucoma care every
one of these injections you look up it
says minimally invasive and this is once
again training they have but the bonus
is just like I had a choice on whether
one or not I wanted to wait for a
physician or go to a nurse practitioner
both trained very well in the field I
had a
choice and our constituents if they
don't feel safe going to optometrist
Maybe they're not there yet they're okay
waiting they still can go see that
opthalmologist but I think it's high
time that the legislature allows
optometrists to a serve our constituency
and B do what they're already trained
for so I ask that you take this into
serious consideration and please pass
House Bill 349 thank
you any questions represent sitech yes
uh you mentioned several states that are
already authorized this yes Oklahoma
started way back uh how about uh
neighboring states New York
Massachusetts Rhode Island do any of
these states permit this process well I
don't have the States written down so I
don't know about any of our neighboring
I never really worry about that too much
because in New Hampshire we like to do
it our own way so I make sure that we
kind of stay true to that but I did not
look that up thank you for the
question other
questions president Howard thank you for
taking my question so I understand that
you've talked a lot about the uh autom
training and I was just wondering if you
knew the difference between uh how much
training the opthalmologists receive
versus the
optometrists um I think there's more
people that can speak closer to that but
um yeah I'm GNA you know I'm going to
leave that for the experts I can say
that I know certainly in anesthesia and
other things like that I have a much
more close relationship but I think that
they can explain that pretty well but I
feel comfortable with our level of
training yes no worries thank you thank
you other questions thank you very much
repres thank you so much representative
Mark
Pearson thank you madam chair and
members of the committee I have written
testimony which I won't read I would
like to summarize it in the interest of
time my name is Mark Pearson I am the
chairman of the children and family law
committee however I spent several years
in the Health and Human Services
Committee of the house the last two is
Chairman and since 2020 I've chaired the
Department of Health and Human Services
oversight committee there were several
medical people in my family including my
wife who is a
physician I have four points to make
number one when my wife started her
medical practice 30 years ago she had to
send a lot of people to
Boston since then special ists have been
moving up and doing one or two days a
week in Andover Mass havil Mass even
plast down to Hampshire last year and
even today it was said that there are
orological
deserts so when this bill was tabled
last year I went to an oologist and I
said what do you think about citing your
people in those deserts I hope that
somebody has brought the testimony I
have seen letters of intent that these
deserts are being being addressed it
will take much less time to go get a
full
opthalmologist to work with
you secondly I Champion the lowering or
elimination of needless
regulations what was it we saw 2,000
hours of training before you could braid
somebody's hair for money I mean
really I also Champion the widening of
scope of practice I was very much behind
the bill
that would train LPNs to the level of
being Med nurses and my Aunt Janet was
one of the first RN in the United States
to become a nurse practitioner so I'm
all in favor of that as long as the
training is there the supervision is
there we've got people who will answer
the speculation about what do
optometrists get in their school versus
opthalmologists and remember
a nurse practitioner isn't a doctor and
an optometrist isn't an MD or a do third
my experience I need an injection into
my left eye every eight weeks I had an
excellent oologist in havil Mass until
he retired now he could have done that
procedure he was
trained as a MD opthalmologist with
extensive postmed school training he
could have done it
but he brought in somebody even further
trained on this particular thing now if
my opthamologist would want to go up the
level I'm not sure I would want to
entrust my eyes to somebody who does
good work in their Lane but is still not
an MD not a doo not an
opthalmologist and then last citations
before boards I read last year's
testimony and it was asserted that the
just isn't
complaints do you remember Dr barbano
from Catholic Medical Center the
Massachusetts Board of
Medicine cited 21 malpractice complaints
against him the New Hampshire board
cited
zero so cheering oversight as I do I
formed a subcomittee we wanted to look
at why was this is the New Hampshire
board derelict what we discovered is
different states have different criteria
for what they report but if I went to
CMC to have surgery and only relied on
the New Hampshire board's statements I
would assume there's no problem here we
found out that wasn't the case so in
conclusion it will be increasingly less
a distance to get an opthalmologist as
they continue to figure out how to site
people in the
deserts
also I think it's very important to
understand what the true level of
training is how many hours of training
and supervised training in an
opthalmologist versus an optometrist
this is not to put people down I have a
nurse practitioner on my staff helping
our physicians it is to say that on
certain procedures we really do want to
be careful our health is on the line so
thank you madam chair and I do have
written testimony I will give over thank
you questions thank you very much oh
excuse me represent sers has a question
thank you madam chair I just want to
make sure I'm clear support or
oppose I'm very much in support of
optometrist but not supporting what they
seek to do here so I would be
opposed representative Howard would
would you be in support of uh helping
increase the educational opportunities
for optometrist so that they could
potentially maybe perform these or is
that going to be too
much if the level of training were
brought to the level that
opthalmologists presently have yeah
that's why I was very much supporting
LPNs being Med nurses if and my aunt
being an RN becoming a nurse
practitioner if thank you for the
clarification thank you representative
Schmidt
briefly I will ask my question Madame
chair with your
respect so uh you
mentioned um nurse
practitioners uh stepping into many
procedures that uh used to be done by
doctors but are currently being
performed by RNs do you know of any RNs
who are performing open hard surgery not
to my knowledge thank you nor any uh no
you thank you representative
pearon is representative Nagel
here okay he said he had a conflict so
good afternoon um I'm Dr Dorothy
hitchmoth um it's always an honor uh to
be asked to provide testimony on behalf
of the people I serve and care for in
New Hampshire and to be clear I'm here
to advocate for improved access and
Quality Health Care especially for those
who have complex medical and eye
conditions I am here to support your
fact find in efforts on behalf of the
safety of my patients my testimony will
be brief but I hope to lay out my
background um and some other data and
facts so that you can call on my
expertise as needed to ensure Clarity
truth and safety for New Hampshire
citizens I will also add that I have
provided testimony to the New Hampshire
and Vermont legislators for over three
decades and had a hand in changing the
laws at least seven times in both States
and not a single poor out outcome
promulgated by our opposition has ever
fruition no pun intended I am an
eyewitness to the good work of Doctors
of
Optometry I've been in practice in rural
New Hampshire for 29 years I'm VA
residency and fellowship trained and
dual boore certified I first used lasers
on live humans in
1996 I'm a professor of both Optometry
and medicine and was the chief of
Optometry at the VA Medical Center in
White River Junction for 22 years I
currently own a private practice and run
a consulting firm that specializes in
the development of medical devices that
help prevent vision loss I'm also a
researcher and Senior journal editor and
have published dozens of scientific
articles book chapters and guidelines on
a variety of ion related diseases of the
body
I am the vice chair of the Board of
Trustees at the New England College of
Optometry in Boston and have taught
Optometry and medical students and
residents from six colleges of Optometry
for over two and a half
decades I have intimate knowledge of
their respective curricula and clinical
training programs and I'm including a
copy of the latest course C curriculum
descriptions for surgical and Laser
procedures from the New England College
of Optometry so you'll all have a copy
of that in
detail the courses as well as laboratory
and clinical practice on real patients
is described furthermore I'm a longtime
consultant for the accreditation Council
on Optometric education acoe as we call
it ACO acoe is the national
accreditation body that ensures
uniformity and
modernization of classroom and clinical
training at all schools or colleges of
Optometry and their affiliate intern and
residency programs
in this role I've worked over the past
several years to ensure accreditation
standards have a minimum competency
reporting system that includes Surgical
and Laser procedures I'm including the
specific La language and
resolutions uh from the AO acoe that
confirms that all colleges teach modern
procedures like those included in the
bill please see also the letter from the
chair of acoe Dr Tim Patito in this
regard furthermore I've served as an
examiner and writer for the national
board of examiners in Optometry and the
American Board of Optometry and I'm here
to assure you there is nothing in House
Bill
349 that is not included in the
curricula for all graduating Doctors of
Optometry despite what you will hear in
testimony here just to be really clear
more importantly I'm here to
confirm uh excuse me that we
continuously improve and upgrade
standards to match
new treatments as they arise the
treatments that were available and that
I did 29 years ago when I first became a
new doctor are not the same as what we
have now things change procedures change
uh research changes furthermore
legislators in both New Hampshire and
Vermont have asked me to provide an
analysis of the curricula at Medical and
Optometry schools and training programs
and I am here to unmistakable
unmistakably repeat respective
equivalencies and we'll provide you with
that analysis as well please remember
that specialty clinical training occurs
years earlier in optometry school
relative to the eye and Associated
disease and includes a human body
systems approach that results in
competency in the treatment of the eyes
and related diseases upon graduation
very similar to
Dentistry this is why my colleagues in
Opthalmology must complete a residency
because they have very little training
in eye disease prior to Medical School
Graduation I test Tes ified in front of
this body many times as I said over 29
years regarding the scope of practice of
Optometry because New Hampshire laws
were outdated and continue to remain so
because we have to come back to this
body on a regular
basis um when new devices drugs or
procedures um become
available when I first testified years
ago I was a new doctor working under
Federal jurisdiction at the VA
I was practicing as I was trained at the
New England College of Optometry which
included rotations that were not in
Massachusetts because you're going to
hear that the school in Boston can't
possibly train people in advanced
procedures because they don't do that in
Massachusetts well that's not true we
send people to the federal system and we
send students elsewhere because they
also have outdated laws in fact they're
one of the the least scope of practice
uh areas so as I said um I was
practicing as I was trained I was able
to prescribe medications any medications
needed for to care for the full spectrum
of eye diseases I was performing minor
surgical procedures and I was laser
certified as I stated before and
continued to do so at the VA however
when I occasionally moonlighted in
private practice my hands were often
tied uh because of restricted and
outdated New Hampshire law I was
dismayed that despite my uh expertise I
was not able to practice similarly the
moment I stepped off Federal
property um I was equally disturbed by
the implication that the VA had this all
wrong I am the daughter of a career Army
veteran who served three tours in
Vietnam I'm the wife of a career Air
Force veteran and my middle son just
completed seven years in Army
intelligence I can assure you that if I
thought the VA was wrong in their repeat
supposition and directives mandating
that all doctors practice at their
highest level I would be the first to
speak loudly in
opposition contrarily the VA and the US
Department of Health and Human Services
have long recognized that Doctors of
Optometry are highly competent
well-trained independently licensed
Physicians and provide a much needed
core service to our nation's finest I
affirm that they do not have this wrong
and have demanded that providers keep up
with medical advancements changes in the
medical Workforce and new scientific
discovery
these facts also make me very
comfortable returning to this
body to further attest that fact the
fact that Doctors of Optometry are
highly highly trained in the care of the
human body to include the visual system
and keeping Pace with modern tools and
to once again highlight that New
Hampshire continues to lag behind the
data continues to show that Doctors of
Optometry who perform the procedures
included in this bill not some of the
procedures that you've already heard
that were referenced cuz we're not
asking for some of the ones that were
referenced already just to be clear um
do so with an exceptionally low rate of
significant or other Adverse Events
across hundreds of thousands of
procedures and you will have that data
in front of you as well I'm also here to
inform you that despite opposition from
the medical society scope of practice
laws were passed in New Hampshire and
across the country and thousands of
patients have been well served now for
almost three decades
and I've been a direct witness to your
good work in this regard um patients
have not been harmed and we continue to
improve access and provide good care
malpractice rates and Adverse Events
outcomes Remain the lowest across many
Specialties I think it's unfair and
inefficient to ask the New Hampshire
legislature to try to keep Pace with all
medical advancements but uh here we are
and hope you will move this bill uh
forward I would respectfully underscore
that no medical profession stands still
there is no Monopoly on
knowledge and Optometry has a solid
national board certification system
uniform training a strong independent
accreditation agency and a state lenser
system designed to protect the public um
today we're asking that you work in the
spirit of New Hampshire's effort to
attract the best and brightest doctors
to our state we must be able to compete
knowing that there's a broad doctor
shortage in the country that is not
going to change it's going to get worse
before it gets better also important is
the difficulty that we have recruiting
new talented doctors I had to work for
five years to find a doctor to join my
private practice I was very lucky to
find Dr Jessica
Eid however as she outlines in the
letter which I will also provide copy of
um and including with my testimony she
was trained in a variety of laser and
other procedures and continued to
perform those procedures in the first
years of practice when she moved to New
Hampshire so that her husband could
complete his res residency in fellowship
at Dartmouth she could no longer use her
skills to treat patients as she was
trained she clearly states in her letter
that she would never have chosen New
Hampshire as a place to practice and
knew that she would be sacrificing her
career goals so her husband could
complete his training more importantly
it's likely she will not stay here
because of the current scope this is
just one example of how the lack of
modernization of our Practice Act is
doing harm to New Hampshire citizens by
preventing the best and brightest
doctors from coming to our beautiful
state finally I'm happy to act as a
resource to this body and anyone else
who without conflict of interest Works
toward my own practice Mission which is
to prevent vision loss and blindness and
I thank you for your time and
consideration and I'm happy to answer
questions but I am providing a pretty
detailed packet for your review with a
lot of data and
curriculum thank you thank you represent
leam uh thank you madam chairman um
thank you doctor for being here could
you let us know um how many how many
times that somebody who's going through
training in school for Optometry is
performing these laser procedures on a
person yeah so that's a really good
question and so it depends on their
specialty right as it does with
Opthalmology if you're a pediatric
specialist you're probably going to do
only the minimum right and so we have
some described minimums in the
curriculum there's some variation um
that is tracked according to whatever
the outcomes are that we're trying to
achieve in a particular residency and I
know that's a messy answer um we have
some minimums that I can give you um
after the hearing that sort of lay
everything out but there are minimums
you have have to be supervised you have
to be supervised on live patients even
before that you have to be supervised in
the lab and you have to go through a
minimum classroom training in fact I
think our training program is more
detailed quite frankly than what it is
in a in a typical surgical residency
followup um as a followup on the
Pediatric would that be something you
can count on my hands or the hands on
the committee just to get a depends on
the procedures so for example you know
if it's a very so the let me back up and
say the three procedures in the bill are
very
lowrisk relatively right everything is
relative safe um procedures we know that
the rate of complications is low already
and so for those it's going to be a low
number so maybe it's going to be 10
procedures for example for a peripheral
iridotomy which is one of the procedures
as an example but it it does vary by
procedure thank you that helps
representative
sellers thank you madam chair uh these L
laser equipment uh do they have
safeguards built in and how can you can
kind of describe and how they are yeah
they're laser that you want to use if
you accidentally press a button to
switch it to another laser for example
there are a lot of combination lasers
that you use on different parts of the
eye or different layers if you will of
the eye um there are protocols that are
preset that prevent you from making a
mistake so yes the answer is yes um
without going into a long laser lecture
represent the freeze thank you madam
chair
um prior to some of these surgeries do
isn't there medication
prescribed so I think you're thinking of
cataract surgery and that's not in the
bill so there are a number of drops that
a patient has to take prior to cataract
surgery um you might talking about GL
the glaucoma laser um if you are
sometimes it's appropriate to prescribe
medication first for a patient that has
glaucoma sometimes it's more appropriate
to do laser first um depending on the
type of glaucoma we have but we're not
doing this is does not include cataract
surgery that requires many more
uh you have to practice that a lot more
and that is in under the purview of
Opthalmology so that's not what we're
asking came for follow up thank you
madam chair
um is was one of these surgeries
typically called lasic no none none none
of these this is not lasic okay so it's
not corrective okay no so there's no
prior to any of these surgeries you were
not provide um prescribing or I don't
know if you have the power to do that we
do to prescribe anti-anxiety medication
because some people get a little worked
up when things start coming at their
eyes so that's often what's done with
lasic it's Al also what I call the
patient needs a happy juice before
cataract surgery that's typically not
required for the procedures in this bill
that wouldn't be common practice thank
you represent
S I had asked this question before you
might know the answer do what
neighboring states in New England here
are have this have authorized these
procedures that the bill talks about so
in New England um
there's none but we have a list of all
the states across the country and
because we've had to go to the
legislature over and over and over again
in every single state you'll see what
looks like a hot mess um but we have
provided that for you so some some
states there are much more invasive
surgical procedures that are allowed and
not lasers and vice versa so I would
encourage you to look at the full list
but there
are upwards of 30 I believe and one of
my colleagues is actually going to give
you the exact numbers um but we'll
provide that but none local it's not
local thank you representa thank you so
you referred to this information that
you've given to us did you email that to
us no it's coming oh okay all right
thank you it's coming sorry okay thank
you thank you very much for your
testimony yeah thank you for the
opportunity representative Ms I have to
apologize your card was buried in the
thank you madam chairwoman and uh and
members of the committee um for the
record my name is Chris muns I am still
one of the four state representatives
from Hampton representing four
representatives from Hampton um I'm here
in support of HB
349 it will allow doctors of optomic to
perform procedures that ODS are
authorized to perform in 12 other states
um but they will not be authorized to do
so until they have been certified by the
New Hampshire Board of registry to
perform uh in op Optometry to perform
those procedures I think that's an
important point a doctoral level uh
degree program in Optometry is comprised
of four additional years of classroom
laboratory and clinical training at an
accredited
optometry school after a student
receives their undergraduate uh
bachelor's degree all such accredited
Optometry schools teach laser procedures
and there are ample opportunities around
the country for the for the proctored
live patient experience that um doctors
need to um uh be certified on these
procedures there is no reason therefore
why someone who has an established and
trusted relation relationship with their
optometrist as I do should have to seek
out someone who they do not know and who
does not know them if they should need
one of these
procedures one of the challenges we have
in our state particularly in some of the
more rural areas is the lack of access
to healthc care providers passing HB 349
will help to address that by expanding
the availability of certified providers
who can provide these Services I urge
you to recommend HB 349 is ought to pass
thank you thank you questions very
already thank you madam chair you have a
handout this yeah we have a handout is
your staff will passing out yes my name
is Kimberly lardi I'm an opthalmologist
practicing in uh New Hampshire at New
Hampshire Eye Associates in Manchester
for the past 15 years I'm the immediate
past president of the New Hampshire
Society of eye physicians and surgeons
and I'm currently serving on the board
for our society I do want to take a
moment to highlight the fact that
Optometry and Opthalmology have
collaborated and worked together for
decades we work together every day and
often and often in the same offices
optometrists are our valued colleagues
our profession couldn't survive without
theirs and vice versa
in fact in 2021 the Opthalmology
community did support the glaucoma
expansion Bill to allow for treatment of
secondary glaucoma and remove some
barriers that existed for optometrists
to obtain their glaucoma certification
we supported that 2021 bill as it was
safe and in the best interest of our
patients this is not the case for House
Bill 349 we oppose HP
349 uh this seeks to allow optometrists
who are not medical doctors to perform
three laser surgeries these Surgical
lasers are already performed by
comprehensive opthalmologists in our
state one procedure is a postcataract
laser surgery the other two are very
distinct glaucoma lasers two of these
are non-urgent surgical procedures and
the third which can sometimes be
emergent is falling out of favor for
standard of care in many
cases um presently 41 States Plus Puerto
Rico and the District of Colombia and
the VA prohibit optometrist from
performing laser surgery this is written
out in VHA directive
1121 subsection 2 appendix
G um of the VHA uh codes uh we would be
the only state in New England permitting
optometrist to perform s surgical lasers
should this legislation pass um
optometrist may receive training in
these lasers the training is didactic
and simulated
only in two states in Kentucky and
Oklahoma is there an optometry school
well where they are allowed to perform
lasers on live humans so Optometry
students must be either relocating to
procedures um other states have passed
similar legislation like Louisiana and
Mississippi they require that their
optometrist have demonstrated their
coursework in optometry school or
they've completed um what is known as
the 32-hour weekend course um both of
which we find inadequate with regards to
surgical training and you have heard
some claims that young optometrists
might be leaving our state to move to
other states where they can perform
lasers of 230 then there's a graph of
this in your packet there's 239
optometrists that filed Medicare Part B
claims from 2013 to 2020 zero filed a
Part B claim Elsewhere for laser surgery
in 2021 that means if they left the
state they did so for other reasons in
fact not being allowed to perform lasers
is not stopping new Young optometrist
from Le relocating to New Hampshire um
from 2013 to 2023 New Hampshire has
added 73 young optometrist giving a
growth rate of
45.8% the population growth rate overall
for our state is only
5.6% so young optometrists are coming to
our state to take advantage of what New
Hampshire has to offer and that goes
well beyond their Licensing Laws we want
to continue to attract quality providers
for the right reasons not so that they
can practice at the top of their
license last year we heard the concerns
about access to um Opthalmic care
particularly in the northern rural areas
as such we are working to formulate a
solution to help bridge this Gap while
maintaining high standards of patient
care and safety you're going to hear
more about this from my colleagues the
solution is not to lower the standard of
surgical care instead we should work
together collaboratively understanding
our differing exper expertise and
ensuring that surgical procedures are
performed by those with necessary
training our community deserves
that thank you are there questions
representative scitech and then Howard
and
then um thank you do Dr lardi
um Dr hitchmoth made the point that
optometrists actually get an earlier
start examining and working with the eye
than opthalmologists even though they're
medical doctors so I guess my question I
don't guess my question is how long is
uh your if after you're a medical doctor
how long is uh your training to be an
opal opthalmologist so after four years
of medical school we either do a
one-year internship in surgery or
medicine or something combined and then
we do three years of Opthalmology
residency and then an additional one to
training Howard thank you for taking my
question uh I just want to ask you if
you knew any uh of the pay differences
between what's available in states that
allow optometrists to perform these
procedures in states that do not so
Medicare rules prohibit having different
um reimbursement rates whether it's an
opthalmologist or an optometrist so they
are there's not a way for them to charge
a lower rate it it would be illegal
actually so follow yeah you I'm not sure
if you fully understood my question it
was kind of more what is there salary
difference between people uh for
optometrists would their salary be say
higher in Kentucky and Oklahoma versus
New Hampshire I can't see why it would
necessarily okay thank
you thank you representative
Schmidt thank you madam
chairman so uh one of the issues that's
been raised even in this go around uh
this time as opposed to the discussions
we had in the previous attempt to um
Institute something along the lines of
this bill seeks uh one of the issues
that been raised is the access for
people in the North Country um and
representative pedell in her testimony
guesstimated that uh completing the
entire legislative procedure and the
other Preparatory steps that would be
necessary to get the optometrist into
this game uh as opposed to uh the
current situation she gu guesstimated
one to two years um if we had a
situation where uh access was
immediately enhanced or speedily
enhanced by providing opthalmological
services to the North country in the
North country as opposed to having
everybody come down here being driven
down by a relative or something like
that uh would that not be uh a much
faster procedure for you for you
opthalmologists to set up some kind of a
situation in the North country where
your colleagues would be up there
providing the service at the level that
you are trained for currently I'm going
to let one of my colleagues get a little
bit time frame I would guess six to
eight months we'd be up and running did
you say a month six six to eight months
six to eight months between
credentialing and some construction that
needs to go on so and do you know
whether followup and do you know whether
there's anything underway for that
matter to try to accomplish that yes in
response to the recognized access issues
yes there is and my f my the colleague
that we have to follow um is going to
elaborate on um this Access Project
thank
you else thank you very
y okay thank you thank you madam chair
members of the committee um and thank
you for the opportunity to speak to you
again in the goal of ensuring that safe
and effective Eye Care is available to
all New Hampshire residents I am Dr
Allison ler born and raised in bford New
Hampshire I am a board certified doctor
of Optometry I graduated from UNH and
received my doctorate from the New
England College of Optometry in Boston I
live in gtown and recently started my
own practice in Milford
some of you may be familiar with the
bill that came before this committee
last year which had unanimous support in
the Senate a unanimous vote in Edna
subcommittee and more than 2third vote
of the full committee before it was
ultimately tabled on the house floor the
bill before you today House Bill 349 is
much more simplified and straightforward
and it seeks to allow three specific in
office non-invasive laser procedures by
Doctors of Optometry these proced
procedures would only be permitted after
meeting certification requirements
defined by the New Hampshire Board of
Optometry which does include a
requirement for live
cases no optometrist would be able to
come here and do lasers on anybody
without having prior experience and
being signed off certified they have
done them on live
patients every optometry school in the
country trains every optometry student
to perform these procedures and these
laser procedures have been performed
safely and effective L by optometrist
for several decades with a proven track
record of
safety Doctors of Optometry complete
extensive postgraduate training
following the completion of a 4-year
undergraduate degree we complete a
rigorous comprehensive four-year
doctorate level program including dactic
laboratory and clinical training which
accumulate to over 10,000 hours of
training and more than 2,000 patient
encounters we do far more than prescribe
glasses and contact lenses we are the
primary eye care providers diagnosing
diagnosing managing and treating ocular
diseases in all 50 states and for more
than 50
years we do not have 10,000 hours in
other surgeries like opthamologists do
we are not trained to deliver babies we
do not do retinal surgeries we are not
trained in cataract surgeries we
have the hours that we are required to
have so we are proficient in the
procedures that we graduate
doing despite our extensive Education
and Training we are restricted from Full
utilization of our skills in this state
with each advancement in training or
technology Doctors of Optometry face
unnecessary battles and delays
ultimately denying New Hampshire
citizens timely care with other
independent healthc care providers
advancements are adopted as they should
be not with legislative battles but with
licensing boards ensuring that
practitioners have the proper education
training and compliance with regulation
the board of Optometry is fully prepared
and qualified to oversee the
implementation of this bill including
the certification and regulation of New
Hampshire Doctors of Optometry to ensure
its
safety I would like to reiterate that
these are all in-office procedures in
fact the lasers used to perform all
three are Incorporated in the same
microscope that every optometrist uses
to evaluate the eye in every single eye
exam and that we are trained to use from
the very first days in Optometry School
the first laser procedure addressed in
houseb 349 is the yag laser capsulotomy
this procedure is used to clear away a
film that can develop after having
cataract surgery the tissue behind the
Cataract implant commonly develops a
film and causes the vision to become
blurry again the yag laser is used to
create a clear opening and restore the
vision the second laser procedure is the
selective laser tcul plasty or SLT this
procedure is used in the treatment of
the most common Common forms of chronic
glaucoma to lower eye pressure by
targeting the drainage tissue for years
SLT has been used as a treatment when
glaucoma drops
fail however research now shows that
this is an effective firstline treatment
prior to the use of glaucoma drops which
can improve quality of life and reduce
health care costs as demonstrated in
several studies this procedure is also
repeatable so if the effects wear off it
can be repeated
safely the third laser procedure is the
laser peripheral iridotomy or an LPI
where a laser is used to create a small
opening in the iris to reduce the risk
of sudden increases in pressure while
this procedure can be performed
preventatively for atrisk patients or
for those with chronic glaucoma it may
be needed in an emergency for those
experiencing acute
glaucoma I have been on call where I
have a patient with very high Skyhigh
pressures and this is when minutes
matter I have the laser in the Next Room
and I have the knowledge and training to
use it and to prevent the patient from
losing vision but I have to set instead
send them to Boston and our patients
deserve
better these three laser procedures are
already permitted in 12 States and they
have been performed by Doctors of
Optometry for more than 30 years
beginning in Oklahoma and it was
actually 1988 when the first laser
procedure was performed by an
optometrist in 1988 evidence shows that
these Optometric procedures are both
safe and effective with more than
140,000 laser procedures performed with
only
0.001% negative
outcomes additionally Optometric
malpractice rates have shown no increase
in the states where these laser
procedures are performed by optometrist
and no state has repealed any
advancement in Optometric privileges
ever lasers or
otherwise some may see this bill as an
expansion of scope but really the
Optometric scope expansion occurred
nearly four decades ago when these
lasers were first performed by Doctors
of Optometry House Bill 349 is a
modernization of the New Hampshire
Optometric statute which has been which
has not seen an update on any
significant level in over 20 years
importantly House Bill 349 does not
permit anything that is outside the
Education and Training of Doctors of
Optometry the opposition our colleagues
in opthomology want you to believe
otherwise you will hear from time from
them time and again that we do not have
the Education and Training for these
procedures that simply is not true what
they really mean is that we do not have
their Education and Training and we
wholeheartedly agree there is overlap
and there are vast differences in the
Education and Training of optometrist
and opthamologists there are hundreds of
procedures and surgeries that
opthalmologists are trained to perform
that are far beyond Optometric training
and beyond that of House Bill
349 medical school is not the sole
institution where in-office procedures
are taught caught or where individuals
can receive a legitimate healthare
education I also want to be clear that
no one is claiming these lasers are
simple or easy these are complex
procedures that are not without risk and
complications as with every procedure in
every healthc care profession there are
negative outcomes although the rate of
complications mon Optometric lasers is
very low it is not zero some of you in
this room may recall hearing from a
patient last year who was brought here
from Oklahoma to tell you of a very
unfortunate outcome from a laser
procedures performed by an
optometrist if you did not hear from her
you may still see her in a video which
opposition is actively working to
distribute among the public and the
legislature what you will not hear from
them however is that the same negative
outcome from her laser procedure has
occurred at the hands of Opthalmology as
well no provider is immune from
complications neither Optometry or
Opthalmology but over 140 ,000
procedures have demonstrated that there
are no increased complication rates when
performed by optometrist as compared to
opthalmologists something else you will
likely hear from the opposition time and
again is surgery by surgeons they paint
the picture of these procedures as being
on par with cataract surgery lasc or
retinal
surgery just today I saw an ad in
opposition showing a surgeon wearing a
um using a scalpel dawned with a
surgical cap a surgical mask and a
surgical gown none of which have
anything to do with these procedures
this is one example of the scare tactics
being used by the opposition to be clear
none of the three laser procedures
addressed in House Bill 349 involve
cutting into the eye or general
anesthesia they are all performed
sitting upright at a microscope just
like the one we use all day every day
these three lasers are used to treat the
conditions that we have been managing
since the Advent of these lasers Doctors
of Optometry have been identifying
appropriate candidates for these
procedures educating our patients on the
risks benefits and Alternatives and have
been managing the associated
complications since they came into use
many of the potential complications are
managed with eye drops which we already
prescribe in the incredibly rare
instance that a retinal Subs specialist
is required Doctors of Optometry would
refer to the subsp specialist just as a
general opthalmologist would do no
matter who is treating the patient the
protocols are the same and we are held
to the same standard of care to
recognize a complication and treat it or
refer as Healthcare Providers we also
share the same professional ethics where
just because we can perform a procedure
does not mean we do when there is a case
that is better handled by our
Opthalmology colleagues we will still
continue to refer those cases and have
an ethical obligation to do so in short
House Bill 349 will modernize the
Optometric Statute in New Hampshire to
be in Greater alignment with the current
Optometric education and train training
that occurs in every optometry school in
the country these procedures are proven
to be safe and effective when performed
by appropriately certified Doctors of
Optometry New Hampshire citizens deserve
access to the full extent of Optometric
care to en to ensure safe quality
comprehensive eye care for
all thank you for your
time thank you
questions um represent bro and then
Howard thank you um
so in the bill it talks about I was on
this committee last year when we heard
this film and one of the things that we
talked about was the training on
live patience yes because I think live
humans I think humans are live right so
yeah live patience and um but it saids
you were able to perform these
procedures with proficiency which I'm
glad to see that word yes so how does
that happen how does how do you become
how can you demonstrate
proficiency well it is how all medical
institutions demonstrate proficiency
where they have Proctors they have um
Educators that are teaching these
procedures that are certified to do them
and they have to pass certain
requirements and proficiencies and if a
student or or a doctor that is going
back for certification is not found to
be proficient in these procedures they
cannot
pass follow up thank you and so where
might
this one of the P that I made at the end
of last year was that opthalmologists
and optometrists would get together to
talk about this training and that
Opthalmology would support you in that
training and has can you confirm or can
is there is no change to that um
historically Opthalmology has not ever
supported any scope expansion they have
opposed it going back decades and
decades and they do not know our
training they haven't had it they
haven't gone through
we have and so we are the ones that
should be speaking about our
training um as far as the glaucoma bill
that they did not oppose the secondary
glaucomas in that
bill were so far outdated that any
argument would have
just been yeah um we were one of the
very last States in fact a lot of us
didn't realize that was still in there
it was more of a an oversight and that
was a
cleanup um as far as another example is
they also opposed us being able to
administer vaccines when 18-year-olds
with a GED can administer vaccines in
this
state thank you thank you representative
Howard thank you for taking my question
uh how many hours uh of training to
optim optometrist go through about
10,000 10,000 all right thank you
represent lamb uh thank you madam chair
um within this whole process there's are
there's national board certification
that you have that's the standard that's
used in other medical professions in
order to determine
competency yeah we cannot obtain lure in
any state without being board certified
and that's on the national level if um
you don't pass you don't get licensed
you don't practice period thank you fell
and that National licensing licensing
board includes the competencies that are
referenced here they are included as far
as dactic portion because they're not
included in every state it is something
you can get an additional certification
in thank you other
questions second question is perhaps
you've picked up from the tone of my
earlier questions I would be far more
comfortable following in a a state like
New York or Massachusetts rather than
than being the pioneer of this can you
speak to why this has not happened in
our neighboring
states well you also don't want to be
last um and we're certainly not first in
the country yes we would be first in New
England which would be obviously we
think a great thing um New York and
Massachusetts
specifically are last because of the
strong medical community presence there
and the opposition in those States and
that's what we believe to be because
Massachusetts you know for being such a
progressive area of the
country um those State states do lag
scope person Bailey question okay anyone
else thank you very much for your
testimony Dr Peters Madam chair I have a
question to the chair yes so how many
have 10 including Dr Peters okay so we
are going to subcommittee with this are
we not yes may I suggest that we not
have all the potential written testimony
read to us aloud believe it or not I am
highly educated and I read quite
proficiently uh and I promise you I will
read everything submitted to us gives me
the option of studying it rereading IT
consulting looking up words I don't know
and so forth and this is not an
efficient way of getting at the core
information that we need we have a lot
of Doctors of Optometry and Opthalmology
here who are taking precious time away
from people who need their attention and
I don't want to sit here and continue to
be read to uh I want to get at the core
information so that we can let everybody
speak before we turn into
zombies yes I and I would say that
somebody that wants to talk for 10
minutes when they have written testimony
should probably work on abbreviating
that
yeah no I I have the chair so Dr Peters
turn the microphone on and please
directly into the
microphone yes sir thank you thank you
representative Leighton everybody um I'm
going to talk about something different
today I'm going to talk about the um
during the last legislature they talked
about the lack of access in the North
country and that's come up quite a bit
today um and quite frankly would I
didn't realize exactly the level of lack
of access in the North country before it
was raised so I began researching it and
I started looking to see who was around
the closest person around is Dr Sawyer
an optometrist um she's you know a
person in one practice she has someone
who works with her um on their practice
website it says that if you're a new
patient expect several months of weight
to be seen for any reason so then I was
like wow this is really a problem we
need to do something about this so I
began working 9 months ago to see what
we can do about bringing this 9% of the
population in New Hampshire care in the
North Country um so I started working
with Andrew gagen Valley Hospital in
Berlin um with their CEO and their CMO
about bringing Opthalmology there to
address the concerns of the citizens and
so for eight months we've been working
on a plan with them in the North Country
Health Care system and we've made
significant progress already uh they've
identified space on their campus for us
uh to do the clinic that will work we've
had an architect design the plans we
have a purchasing equipment list and
everything ready to go site visit is the
next um thing and I'm meeting with there
with him and uh the the CEO Mike
Peterson and the CMO and the other
representatives of the North Country
healthc care system to iron out the
remaining details um CEO Peterson has
said that he expects that this is this
is their one of their number one
priorities for 2025 and he expects this
program to be up and running in 8 to 12
months um this is going to address not
only these three laser surgeries these
three laser surgeries are literally
maybe at most 1% of what we do this is
not solving access to anyone anywhere
it's really not a true
statement um this is a tiny little
sliver of optology what people in the
North Country need they need care for
their diabetic retinopathy they need
care for their immacula degeneration
they need care for their glaucoma their
cataracts you know and yes these laser
procedures would be great one these are
mostly one-time procedures right um but
they need this ongoing care you know um
you had a representative speaking about
how he gets a shot in his eye every six
to eight weeks you know that's macular
degeneration right you need that
repeatedly so this bill would not
address that but our plan does so we
have over 25 opthalmologists who've
agreed to rotate up there and provide
twice a month coverage in
Berlin um and this um is really a
significant step forward um we're
pleased that we can offer a free market
solution from Granite Staters to Granite
Staters in Berlin um without the need
for
legislation um so we're excited about it
and I welcome any questions on the topic
and I try to keep it
short thank you any questions from the
thank you doctor thank you madam chair
uh so uh you heard
my hypothetical question earlier in the
testimony in the hearing with regard to
whether it would not be more expeditious
to get the top and most
important level and and number of of
treatments to North Country in North
Country uh by opthalmologists so that we
are not limiting ourselves to the three
uh procedures uh that this bill seeks to
implement in New Hampshire uh can you
can you uh you already gave me a
guesstimate of six to eight months um
representative petal suggested a year to
two years just to get through the uh
legislative end of things and the
training end of things uh can we see
some uh some written information at some
point soon in the subcommittee perhaps
which will lay out what you describing
to us in outline form yes sir I'd be
happy to provide that we we have all of
that um I I think it's going to be great
it literally covers all of the needs of
the people there on site AVH does this
with other Specialties they're used to
doing this um so when we started this
process they're like we know how to do
this we can get this done and we want to
get it done this calendar year um and
this can serve as a role model for other
Specialties to bring other types of
access to the North Country not just
opthomology followup follow up thank you
madam chair so the thing is um obviously
there are a whole series of things
between the opto are you going to
include some opto
optometrists that you will bring with
you as part of the team that you are
talking about that obviously Focus is on
opthalmological uh
opthalmological um procedures because
those are the most critical and crucial
ones and the ones that are clearly not
being provided in the North Country at
this time but some things are clearly
also
optomet Specialties are you going to
provide that as well at this Hospital in
the North country and which one would
that be so we're working currently with
AVH and and I believe the North Country
Healthcare plan is to bring the other
members of the North Country Healthcare
to Berlin to get these Services there is
optim optometrist care in Berlin Dr
Sawyer and her partner I can't remember
her name are there um and happy to work
with them we used to work with them all
the time we used to work literally in
their office um with them so happy to
continue that I don't know that um you
know unless Dr Sawyer says she wants me
to bring somebody I don't know that I
need to bring anyone to help
her I
I question I won't I won't ask you all
the other questions I have but but uh um
it would be helpful if some of you could
come to the subcommittee because we need
to work through a lot of these details
of what you're talking about and what
the optomet are talking about in a way
that it's not practical in a hearing yes
sir
representa thank you so this um look
into expanding into the North country
came as a result of the bill that we had
last year yes ma'am and um follow up
follow up I'm sorry follow up so um
that's fine but that doesn't really
address this bill this addresses this
bill and I mean that doesn't address
House Bill
349 and I thank the um
optometrist for bringing that to your
attention but I also would like you to
discuss or your share your thoughts on
Poss what their training plans are on
live um patients and proficiency and
allowing them to also do what they have
been trained to do yes ma'am this
addresses what I believe is one argument
this North Country project addresses
what I believe is one argument for the
bill that there is a lack of access and
that this would solve access um even if
pasted this is a minuscule portion of
access to iare in the North Country so
it's not really valid and this goes well
beyond that I don't support the bill on
the training purposes um I've had
conversations um about what training
really
is the bill says that when you guys pass
this if it gets passed we'll take it to
the board of Optometry and they'll
decide what training is and it will
include live cases right it could be one
to Dr lean or representative lean's
point it could be five it could be 10
could be whatever they get to decide
what it is right in the other states
that it has been approved it's been a
32h hour course um followed by maybe a
live case and maybe not with in the
other 10 states in the country um I do
have Optometry residents at our program
from the three Local Schools well two
local um New England College of
Optometry Pacific College of Optometry
in Pennsylvania and the one in um in
Memphis um and they get dactic training
in these procedures so they've heard
about them they've read about them
they've seen videos about them they've
learned about them in in in textbook
setting right there's 24 Optometry
schools in the country two are in states
that allow this procedure these are not
very frequent procedures right so the
concept that all 100% of the students
from the 22 other Optometry schools are
going to fly to the two schools and see
and do enough live cases on live humans
while they're there for a week a weekend
whatever and come back and be trained
it's not really mathematically feasible
so the training just the training is is
a hangup if you ask how I feel about the
rest of
it yes sir representative
sellers thank you madam here so do you
see this bill going forward with any
changes to it
maybe I I don't know what the changes
would be um you're you're talking about
can you you know if you're talking about
can you train a person to do surgery yes
sir right that those are called medical
students we have a way to do it they're
approved nationally accredited residency
programs they take three to five years
to complete and you get good surgeons at
the end right the question here is is
can you do that in a significantly
truncated fashion and still deliver
trained surgeons or
not I thank you other questions
representative Rees thank you madam
chair um we heard in some of the earlier
testimony that some of the waiting times
were three three and a half months for
surgery and that wasn't I don't believe
only limited to the North Country so
while I am quite enthusiastic about this
as a solution uh traveling
opthalmologist headed up to Berlin um
I'm also concerned about bandwidth um
across the state so I guess my question
is if I could articulate it is if this
were approved and if optometrist were
able to take um and expand the bandwidth
on these three surgeries would it allow
opthalmologists to bring down weight
times so heard about some painful eye uh
situ ation and faster sounds better in
those circumstances would that allow uh
the opthalmologist to bring down average
weight times and is that something I
suppose double question here um that you
are committed to addressing yes ma'am
thank you um so Dr Blake is going to
address what the real weight times are
in in the other 90% of the state I can
tell you from my I have a large practice
out in the Sea Coast Area we've got five
or six locations we do we have openings
every week so there's really no waight
at all it's more of a wait to get to see
me for something as opposed to get to do
these procedures CU this is a tiny
little bit of what we do um I did
appreciate the last testimony I will say
though that having seen somebody most of
these are non-urgent almost the vast
majority 99 and a half% are non- Urgent
right of the of that tiny little
fraction that is urgent these people
come in they're miserable they're
vomiting they can't see they're scre
screaming and crying you can't touch
them the anesthetics don't work real
good the corne is super emitus you can't
see through it to do these procedures
it's really really challenging for
someone who's done thousands right I
doubt that in this residency training
program they're ever going to see
someone who's looks like that yet alone
get experience treating someone like
that um I wouldn't start with a person
like that you know if someone like that
walked into my office and I'd done a
handful of these things
I would be getting someone else to help
because they're super
challenging thank
you other question thank you very much
thank
good afternoon Madam chair um members of
the committee thank you um it's an honor
for me to have the opportunity to speak
to you today um I am Dr Angelique Sawyer
of Infamous Berlin Fame apparently um I
am originally from nasua uh I am an
optometrist and I'm a practice Private
Practice owner in the Far nural Far
rural Northern parts of our great state
having office locations in both North
Conway and Berlin where I have practiced
for the last 12 years
um I am here today to speak in support
of House Bill 349 because it is what my
patients your constituents and the
citizens of New Hampshire deserve in
order to better meet their ey care needs
before I go further into my prepared
testimony I do want to um clarify some
of the the questions that have already
come forward yes and I would reiterate
representative Schmidt's comment that
you should not read your testimony yes
you should give us the highlights
absolutely us so um one highlight is
that yes I am in Berlin and um I uh am
surprised to hear of this collaborative
effort that not a single optometrist has
been approached about for any of the
North Country efforts um
I uh have spoken to several to every
optometrist that practices in the North
country and not a single one has been
approached about any of this
collaborative care um they they speak
about you know our relationships and
that they're seeking to collaborate as
um representative groa had asked and as
um was put forward to us last year to
sit down with them and attempt to find a
compromise and I sat at that meeting and
I said one single procedure anything
what would it take for you to approve
and for you to be comfortable and to not
oppose having this happen What would the
pathway be for an optometrist to get
there crickets there is nothing that
they will allow that will let us have
this short of going to medical school
because to them one procedure requires
medical school don't know their their
motives you can just speak please only
testify to what they have said or done
um they told me that if I wanted to go
to medical school I could perform these
procedures thank you thank you
um they the question question was asked
about
um um live requirements I did my
schooling in the state of Texas when I
was in Texas um and still Texas is not a
state that is allowed to do that um
however I did my rotation through
Oklahoma while I was in school I did
these procedures on live patients we
have doctors in the state of New
Hampshire who have experienced
performing these in other states that
have come to New Hampshire how we get
these procedures is starting with those
cases starting with those providers who
have live experience starting with um
Educators who have taught these
procedures and who then supervise New
Hampshire optometrists in performing
these procedures that is how we get
there we can't start doing these
procedures in states where it's not
allowed and so we can't get there if we
don't have a pathway so that is where we
are starting here we are starting with
three procedur procures that every
optometrist in the country is trained to
do at every optometry school many of
them have hands-on experience performing
them on patients as part of their
training by going to rotations in places
where they can do those training those
procedures on live patients for those
that do not have that opportunity and
some some do not have the interest some
optometrists do not plan to do these
procedures they do not plan to
specialize and to to do this type of
care and they will not pursue that there
are many Optometry students who do not
look to find seek out those rotations
where they can get that clinical
experience because it is not one of
their priorities but for those that do
we need to have a pathway to get there
and that is where this is coming from we
have had 12 states that have developed
this pathway we're not Reinventing the
wheel we have states that we will model
model after the state of Kentucky their
Board of Optometry has a proctoring
program where established doctors
oversee doctors that are looking to have
live patient experience this is the
model that our state board will be able
to follow um the it is mandated in this
uh law in in the bill HB 349 that live
experience will be required and that
will be done under supervision by those
who are approved as educators of these
procedures
years um the question came up about um
you know the differences in in education
it was brought forward you know that
this was a um a 32-hour course the
32-hour course is the refresher course
that builds on our four years of
doctorate Level Training where we are
trained to do these
procedures there as mentioned there are
many procedures that up opthalmologists
are trained to do that we are not and
that we will have no intention of ever
trying to do that is not within our
training um in uh regards to the number
of minimums we intend for that to be um
decided by the board of Optometry in
rule making but as a guideline the acgme
that regulates Opthalmology residencies
they have a minimum of five procedures
four or five depending on which of the
three laser procedures that we're
talking about that is the minimum
requirement for an
opthalmologist that is a starting point
where our board can go from in uh
comparison to that there are over 200
other minimums that they need to meet so
14 laser procedures among 200 other
surgeries in that Opthalmology
residency so I do not need to go do an
Opthalmology residency and do a minimum
of all those other 200 procedures to do
these three laser procedures these three
laser procedures are ones that I have
have been trained to do and that I have
done safely and effectively on live
patients in Oklahoma
myself I have patients in Berlin who I
cannot provide this care
to um I have we I I'm thrilled to hear
about this collaboration of bringing
care to the the North Country um as
representative groa pointed out this was
not something that was ever brought up
until we brought forward our um our bill
last year and that is is not for lack of
trying because as as in my written
testimony um we had a provider who was
traveling to the North Country who
ceased to do so because it became too
burdensome we've had AVH looking to
bring provider to the North Country for
years for three years they had a single
person who came and spoke so I am
thrilled if this is something that
becomes successful um I hope that it
will become a collaboration and this
could become an opportunity where
optometrists can receive training to
then become certified to do these
procedures because regardless of the
access issue whether there were one or
not this is within the training
education and certification of Doctors
of Optometry and that's what this bill
is about my testimony and is almost
entirely about access I have patient
stories about you know they they mention
that these these procedures are not um
urgent they're not things that you know
typically need to be done um very
critically there's a a testim uh a
patient story in my testimony here um of
a patient who was blind in one eye and
had to wait six weeks after going to see
the opthalmologist and being told yes
you need this laser procedure and then
was sent back home and had to wait six
more weeks to have that procedure done
they were already blind in one eye and
during those six weeks they cannot drive
they cannot function
and that is the level of care and this
is somebody who is in Carol County
because there is one opthalmologist in
all of Carol County there is no
opthalmologist in all of Coos County
there are there are two counties that
have no opthalmologists and there are
two counties that have a single one
there is an access issue but that is not
why HB 349 should pass HB 349 should
pass because these three specific
procedures are within the education the
certification and the training of
Doctors of Optometry there has been
proven in 12 States over 140,000
procedures over more than 30 years of
success and very low complication rate
the question has been asked about
neighboring states no there are no other
states in New England right now that
have this but if that is the requirement
is to wait until other neighboring
states have that we will find ourselves
at the bottom of the list Massachusetts
and New York are at at the very bottom
of the list for Optometric scope those
are the two states that have continually
been at the very bottom of where
Optometry students look at what can I do
as an optometrist New York and
Massachusetts are on the bottom so if we
would like to wait until those go
forward so that we can do
that that's not the New Hampshire that I
grew up in and that I knew and that's
I'm hoping is not the New Hampshire that
I live in we have 12 States whether they
are neighboring or not that have done
this successfully that have a track
record of safety we are not proposing
any sort of reduced quality of care in
order to save on health care costs or in
quarter to increase access we are
looking to expand at the same level of
quality care and that is what has been
proven by the track record of 30 years
of optometrists doing these laser
procedures I'm sure there's more I plan
to say but that's all I got right now
thank you any questions representative
Schmidt so my eternal infernal question
is can you come to the subcommittee
because we need this kind of specificity
to move this forward absolutely I was
there last year I'll be happy to do it
again thank you very much thank you and
other questions seeing none thank you
for your
testimony
okay all the remaining uh people who
have filled out cards are in opposition
so I would hope you wouldn't be careful
smid thank you madam chair I'm uh here
as just a concerned member of the public
I am not a medical doctor nor am I an
optometrist uh I would just like to
respond to some things that I heard
earlier in the testimony so one concern
that I have just looking at the bill is
if these are op omrs that want to
practice opthalmological
procedures I question why they don't
just choose to become
opthalmologists from the get-go and one
of the problems I have is if we start
Sor if we start cheapening the
profession of uh opthomology and allow
optometrist to practice these
opthalmological procedures it provides a
negative pressure on the training of
opthalmologists in the future because
why would you become an opthalmologist
go through med school put yourself
through uh what I heard was a 6year plus
post uh Residency program why would you
go through that if you can just study
Optometry and then practice opical
procedures just because of the
legislate it does not make sense to me
uh and I would not feel comfortable not
knowing the difference between the two
because again the words are very similar
Optometry and opthomology uh if I was
just a Layman going to see a doctor and
and I did not know the two I would feel
very uncomfortable learning that the
profession uh professional that I had
chosen to see uh did not have the
training that I believed when walking
into that office and for many people
they cannot make that distinction uh
because they just don't have time to
learn the difference between various
Fields I would like to end by saying if
as I heard State statutes determine uh
opthalmological practices and Optometric
prac
practices this is unique in this
profession however if other professions
were in similar stances I would not
expect that the state allow flight
attendance to uh Captain airplanes or
any such other uh cross within a
profession that we have specific
occupations that tie back to uh specific
delineations of uh study and and
care also I'd like to note that when uh
it was asked why Massachusetts was not
leading the charge on allowing
optometrist to practice these opical
procedures it was said they have a large
medical community that does not support
it I do think that we should follow the
recommendations of this large medical
community and also not support it thank
you thank you for your testimony
representative Leon has a question if
you would here to answer it oh yes thank
you your testimony has definitely been
impressive um just with your know level
of detail are you do you have any family
members that are in this area uh yes my
dad is a practicing opthamologist okay
that's why you get this area so much
thank
you uh any other questions I don't see
any thank you thank
I'm Timothy Blake I'm an opthalmologist
in nashwa uh I'm in opposition to HB 349
I appreciate the committee's attention
this afternoon I'm going to touch on a
couple points regarding access uh New
Hampshire is favorably positioned
compared to the average State regarding
Drive times to an opthalmologist over
90% of New Hampshire residents live
within a 30 minute drive to an
opthalmologist
furthermore uh every optometry office
that serves New Hampshire Medicare
patients Falls within a 30 minute a 30
mile catchman area of an opthalmologist
office this is intuitive NASA is a small
state by area the seventh smallest in
the union the states where legislator
have experimented with authorizing
optometrist laser ey surgery privileges
are the states with the lowest
population density Alaska and wyom
filing for example are ranked 50th and
49th respectively in Residence per
square mile New Hampshire has more than
twice the population density of the
average State allowing optometrist Las
laser eye
surgery the Bureau of laser of Labor
Statistics ranks New Hampshire third in
the country in Opthalmology employment
per 1,000
jobs I'm not this is in your your packet
by the way I'm not a demographer but I
believe one could use this as a stand in
for relative opthalmologist per
capita the statistic speaks highly of
the general presence of Opthalmology in
New Hampshire relative to other states
access the average weit time to see an
opthalmologist in New Hampshire for an
after cataract laser is two weeks
according to surveys with 75%
opthalmologists responding and and the
full survey results also are in your
packet I'd also like to um make a note
that uh one of the other testifiers
briefly did uh regarding access and
affordability uh increasing the number
of providers for a medical service does
not decrease the cost to patients there
is no price demand curve for Medicare
covered Services the cost to patients
and insurers is flat
and dependent basically on Medicare
surgery does the number of patients in a
rural location support the number needed
to treat to achieve an adequate and
proficient skill
set studies in the surgical literature
demonstrate that one of the most
important predictors of surgical
complications is low surgical volume
surgeons who do fewer surgeries than a
complications and I'll I'll touch on one
final Point uh it's it's been brought up
this year and on occasion last
year uh many professions can lean
heavily on onth job training that occurs
after schooling however laser eye
surgery training needs to address the
very difficult problem of all surgery
training the problem is reconciling
these two conflicting fla facts new
trainees will make mistakes and there is
zero tolerance for mistakes in
surgery this difficult problem is why on
the PubMed database the topic surgical
training has more than 20,000
peer-reviewed entries I'm not a
residency director but I would describe
surgical training as slow and
incremental
establishing a foundation on
fundamentals and building fundamentals
upon those
fundamentals surgeon Proctors
recognizing each trainee is different
responding to different prompts at
different
speeds it's recognizing some trainees do
not have the skill sets and despite the
strong tendency of self-denial in a
trainee who has invested years needs to
we have heard here today that access may
not be the important issue that it is
the training of
certification and still the training
education and certification of 21 of 23
Optometry schools does not include
procedures on live
patients in this country the acgme the
accreditation Council for graduate
medical education established in 1981 is
the institutional embodiment of
post-graduate surgery training the acgme
set standards for surgical
residencies the council for podiatric
medical education set standards for
podiatric surgery residents Kota
Commission on Dental accreditation
establishes criteria for oral
surgeons these organizations set a floor
for surgical training and accredit
surgic IAL residencies based on the
expanding body of training research and
the best interest of Public Health thank
you questions representative sellers you
have a question thank you madam chair uh
question is do you do laser laser
surgeries yes follow up follow and the
second part of that is when you were in
training do you make
mistakes uh not on live patients okay
but you mentioned mistakes and everybody
makes them that's why I was
asking
please I'm just being clarified because
the word every everyone and not that
just means it includes a lot everyone
absolutely thank you do you need
I think thought you were perfectly clear
questions thank you very much thank
thank you madam chair and um members of
the Edna committee for allowing me to
testify on this bill HB HB
349 I am retired orp surgeon hav been
practiced in this state for about 40
years I'm also a past member of the
House of Representatives here in New
Hampshire serving on ways and means as
well as HHS I'm here to
testify as strongly as I can against uh
HB uh 349 several here have given
testimony and I won't reiterate this and
for the sake of uh what representative
Smidt uh asked I will not try to read my
testimony but we'll try to summarize it
thank you um some people here will
testify that this bill is identical to
what happened last year and years before
that and failed twice uh others will
basically state that um uh they heard
testimony that there was reporting from
the optom optometrist own Review
Committee that there were no
complications where we heard somebody
last year uh testify that somebody
suffered from significant blindness
after a procedure done by an
optometrist
um also that the board of Optometry
would decide decide who would have the
credentials to uh perform these
surgeries but failed to recognize that
um uh doing a weekend course on not live
patients does not really compare to the
multiple years that it takes to become a
surgeon I'll not reiterate those
testimonies um but I cannot stress hard
more than enough that this is simply a
quality of care issue as far as I'm
concerned this is not a Turf battle I'm
an orthopedic surgeon uh I'm not an
optomologist I'm not an optometrist I'm
an orthopedic surgeon but I can easily
relate to the practice of surgery that
uh in the tension that may exist between
opthamologists and optometrists this is
really not a Turf battle uh I been
involved in Turf battles before in the
state Turf battles sometimes would in
Center in my specialty who would do hand
surgery would it be um plastic surgeons
general surgeons orthopedic surgeons we
basically came to an agreement that if
you were board certified if you have
done the appropriate training that you
you could probably do the hand surgery
appropriately and frankly it was welcome
because it was more than enough to go
around
um but I do know what it takes to be a
surgeon um I know the required training
to do so uh weekend courses limited to
uh patients that are not live is simply
not adequate
surgical residencies can take anywhere
from six to 10 years um Orthopedics is
relatively simple we are basically you
know Cabinetry makers on the human body
um but having said that that comes after
four years of med school five years of
surgical training another year of
Fellowship um we work side by side with
trained surgeons experienced surgeons
day and night to to learn our our trade
having optometrist do laser surgery
would be akin to having the occupational
therapist do your hand surgery or the
physical therapist to do your knee scope
they have doctors of physical therapy
that is one of the um uh titles that
they can carry doctor of physical
therapy but they do not do surgery they
reason surgical training is really just
not an exercise in the O it's learning
indications it's learning um
decisionmaking about who goes to the or
who does not I would estimate that
probably 90% of the patients I saw in
the clinic did not go to surgery but 10%
probably did uh it's about how to take
care of complications how to recognize
complications and how to deal with them
the surgical training that we went
through took up to probably 10 years and
as a result um we were equipped to
handle many of the problems that we saw
on the the outside I can't tell you how
many times I had residence I was a
residency director at one point at
Dartmouth as well I was there for about
10 years as a director of orthopedic
surgery I can't tell you how many times
I would have a resident call a past
resident call years later and say murf
I'm seeing something that I have never
seen before and I would remind
them that during the training they may
have not seen that specific case but
during the training they had the
principles taught to them so that that
they applied the appropriate principles
they could take care of the cases and
nearly 100% of the time they could so
surgical training is not just a
technical exercise I would I would
mention that the um the bill that's
before you mentions laser procedures
don't be mistaken these are laser
surgeries these are surgical
procedures this is truly not a Turf
battle between the optometrist and the
optomologist
it is because of professional education
patient safety and quality of care that
is important it's why surgical
residencies take so long so our
objection my objection to this bill is
not as a surgeon needing to maintain any
ego I am
retired um it is not a Turf Battle of US
versus them it is not about access to
care I've heard about access before I I
totally agree that there is an access
problem in healthcare across the the
country it's in primary care it's in
Orthopedics it's in in any specialty you
mention it's also in the trades it's in
the electricians and the plumbers if you
do not have the appropriate you expect
when you have somebody come to your
house to take care of the plumbing that
they are certified in what they do when
you go to the hospital you expect that
the people that are credentialed and
privileged there have the the right to
do the surgery that they intend to do on
you so I I wouldn't argue I I would not
argue that is not a problem but this is
simply a quality of care issue surgeons
are trained to take care of surgical
problems these are surgeries and I I
would just say that um I would urge you
and I would be happy to come into
subcommittees to give you more technical
details though I'm not an
opthalmologist but I would urge you to
itl this bill because it really is about
patient safety quality of care
professional credentialing
uh practice scope that we were talking
about here thank you thank you for the
testimony representative Leon thank you
madam chair and very very good to see
you again we're missing you in the
legislature this year um my question you
actually touched upon what I've been
thinking been wondering about throughout
this whole hearing um here we have an
issue of putting certain procedures into
the statutes but in surgery is it the
statutes that prevent an orthopedic
surgeon from performing cardiac surgery
is that the Board of Medicine that is
actually probably done at the hospital
level so when you think about it when we
have when we go to a hospital to
practice they have a credentialing
committee and they have a privileging
committee the credentialing committee
basically says that you have the
credentials that you talk about you went
to med school you did your surgical
residency you did your fellowship Etc
you passed your
boards the privileging is what I spent
many hours on the side of the bed
operating on Open Hearts on brain
surgery other surgical subsp Specialties
general surgery I am not qualified and
was never qualified after my training to
do that that is where the privileging
comes in so really it is up to the
hospitals to decide where and who what
you should be doing and in fact even
within the bread of Orthopedics I had to
limit what I I took on as my privileged
case load that I could do because I'm
not qualified to do some of the stuff
that you know I started off in general
Orthopedics I did spine surgery I did
joint surgery I did a lot of trauma But
as time went on I retracted back to my
Subs specialy of hand surgery and
frankly I did not feel like I was
comfortable doing so I checked off the
box that I'm not qualified so it's at
the hospital level really that it should
be done thank you follow and as a
followup that's done at the hospital
level but things like the hospital
accreditation really move that more to
National standards around who should be
performing what procedures correct
that's true thank you other questions
thank you very much for your testimony
Nagels thank you Madame chairman this
has been an entertaining day we go from
Cannabis to psychology to opom Tre I'm
David Nagel I'm a physician I'm also
representative
um
um and I I'll leave it at that I am a
nonsurgeon um I don't really want to
repeat a lot of what Dr Murphy just said
but I was honored last year to be asked
on that subcommittee thing that we kind
of looked at this whole process and it
was really neat that the two gentlemen
that teach these elect and how to do
these procedures were present so that we
were able to ask them questions and I
think that's where things really started
to bother me um we asked some very basic
qu or I did or um some very basic
questions about well how do you teach
these people and there you know the
first question that I asked them how do
you teach and let let me take a step
back Optometry from what I understand is
a four-year degree me going to medical
school that's a four-year degree my
understanding was the training they got
in doing these procedures was a three to
four- week elective in their senior year
um and that so I wanted to know exactly
what happens in that time frame the
first question I asked how do you teach
the answer was see one do one teach one
does anybody here know what that means
it means that you see one you do one and
you teach one and I will guarantee you
that is not how you learn surgery that
is probably the worst way to learn how
to teach surgery so the next question I
asked well how many procedures does each
student get to do as a um primary
surgeon and uh the one both of them
answered the question I don't know and I
looked at him I says you don't know and
I said oh okay and then so we're not
allowed to be mean so I wasn't mean so
the third question that I asked was well
what's your outcome data and the answer
was oh our patients do great and I said
what does that mean you know and there
was no answer as far as we knew there
was no outcome data collected so we
followed up on that and we asked some
other people they go so where's your
outcome data then they said well the
outcome data is pretty much would you
expect from somebody that had limited
training too often we see inappropriate
diagnosis inappropriate procedure um
um in inadequately done so that needs to
be repeated so all obviously there's a
cost there so it seemed to me that this
is I'll be honest I I don't have a
problem with scope creep which this
functionally is um podiatrists have done
it you know how Podiatry did it so they
were a non-surgical specialty they added
a 4 to sixe Residency program to learn
how to do surgery of the foot veterinary
medicine they did the exact same thing
if you want to be a Veterinary surgeon
it's four to six years beyond your your
medical school training Dentistry does
the exact same thing Physical Therapy
when they decided that they wanted to
scope creep get more into dependence and
what do they do now they require a
doctorate level to become a PT that to
me seems the right way to do this so
when I've asked around well what do you
think an optometrist would need to be
able to do these three procedures and
the answer was a minimum of a one to
twoe Fellowship probably with op op
nobody can say that word opom you guys
got to come up with a new name for your
specialty Opthalmology we were talking
about that last night um you know you
know with Opthalmology oversight because
those guys are the experts and then you
know you there's a limited number of
procedures you can do that may or may
not help access the folks from Kentucky
told us that these bills did not improve
access but um that's what they said um
but I think that's the right way to go
about doing a scope creep to just come
in and say I'm going to do a three-week
elective or a four-week elective my
senior year and then think that I can go
out and do this and you know
independently I I have a big problem and
the other little minor detail T I did a
lot of surgery as a as a before I went
to med school I was a world famous
rodent surgeon um um I
also you know did a lot in med school
and then I did a thing with the Indian
Health Service in Alaska where I did a
lot of surgery um and when I came out of
there the first thing I knew was I
didn't know enough to be doing this for
a living and that I would never do it
without as um rep or Dr Murphy now Dr
Murphy said without formal training so
in some I think there's a pathway
forward but this is not it and I think
the op optometrist really needed to
start thinking about you know let's
create a fellowship let's get our people
adequately trained and then then they
can legitimately start solving the
problem of
access thank you are there
questions seeing
none representative Schmid are thank you
madam chair so are you aware of what Dr
Peters talked to us about this afternoon
that they've got a working arrangement
it seems with Andrew
Goen uh they think they're maybe six to
eight months before they could start up
doing their practice up
there that they would go up there and so
forth uh are you aware of that and do
you have a comment on that I think it's
wonderful um I would bet 30 as you know
also doctor about 30 at least 30% of my
patients live in the North Country um I
would love to see them up there and I
talked to them all the time do you have
a problem with lack of access to a
specialist like me up there and the
answer always is no he says we made a
conscious decision to live up here and
we understand that there's certain
things we're going to have to travel for
and they have absolutely no problems
coming down to see me and conquered in
Ideal World yeah we would have every
specialty up there imaginable but I
think you know we would focus on primary
care and not surgery and Specialty Care
things like this if we have to focus on
something so to answer your question if
they're doing that it's
wonderful thank you you other questions
seeing none thank you I just have I have
one question did did you use the word
rodent
yes um I did I hear that correctly you
did hear that correctly I was an onc I
was in oncology research before I went
to med school and I oper ated on
hundreds of rodents who did very well
until I sacrificed
them okay it's so good to know that
please thank you madam chairman and
thank you to the members of the
committee and thank you all for your
service to our wonderful State of New
Hampshire my name is Christy Morse I'm a
board certified practice in Pediatric
opthalmologist here in conquer and I'm
here to oppose House Bill
349 my opposition to House Bill 349 in
no way um discounts the contributions
and essential services that optometrists
provide we have three optometrist in our
practice and we work as a collaborative
team I also can attend the subcommittee
hearing just to answer the question
about the states that have um scope
expansion there are actually 10 states
not 12 Oklahoma Kentucky Louisiana
Arkansas Mississippi Wyoming Colorado
South Dakota Virginia and Alaska most
large rural states that about five of
New Hampshire could fit into Also to
clarify about the VA directive
1132 the US Department of Veterans
Affairs issued that veterans Health
Administration directive that specifies
quote only opthalmologist will be
privileged to perform therapeutic laser
procedures of the eye and the eyelids at
the Department of Veteran Affairs
medical
facilities and currently the optometrist
are lobbying the federal government in
order to do the lasers so they cannot do
lasers at VA facilities now this bill
would allow optometrist to perform
surgery on the inside of one of the most
sensitive complex and important parts of
our bodies Our
Eyes I'm going wanted to talk to briefly
about managing the complications that
can arise from these procedures not
being able to manage these complications
can lead to significant vision loss
that's important because if urgent
additional surgery is needed as a result
of a complication optometrist would not
be able to perform those sight saving
techniques in contrast opthalmologists
or train surgeons who have undergone the
training to perform safely and manage
any complications that arise
here are just a couple of examples laser
iridotomy and Laser trabeculoplasty can
lead to bleeding in the eye and high
pressure If severe enough the fluid may
need to be surgically evacuated from the
inside of the eye and the inability to
manage that complication in real time
could lead to vision loss preventable
vision loss during laser capsulotomy the
laser can put craters um in the lens
inside the eye that lens may need to be
replaced if during l capsulotomy the
laser opens up too much of the capsule
the lens could fall back into the back
of the eye and then have to go in to
have another surgery to pull that lens
out and replace it um and there's always
a risk of retinal detachment with laser
surgery the procedures to treat any of
these complications are performed by
opthalmologist and any reoperation or
revision surgery is far more difficult
than the original surgery as I said
they're currently 10 states that allow
laser surgery to be performed by
optometrist in most of the states that
allow optometrist to perform surgery
there is no requirement to report the
negative outcomes of laser surgery to
the board of
Optometry a study by Nathan louser and
or optometrist who wrote the study
claims that optometrist can safely
perform capsulotomy surgery the medical
community has a few concerns with that
publication the study May induce
selection bias because it does not
include P the patients nor the
optometrist were randomized and it does
not indicate that the participants in
this study were those serially eligible
to participate in the study second the
results of the study are not
generalizable because the experience of
the Arthurs is likely far more extensive
than the optometrist who would be
performing those procedures in New
Hampshire lastly the study shows no
significant adverse effects but as we've
heard from Real World experience we know
that not representative of laser
surgery furthermore there's a study
published in a major medical journal
that looked at
1,384 eyes of patients that underwent a
surgical laser procedure used to treat
glaucoma in Oklahoma the study found
that there was
189% increased Hazard of requiring
additional laser treatment in the same
ey when the surgery was performed by an
optometrist compared to the same laser
done by Opthomologist let me repeat that
I know one representative here likes
numbers in percentage a
189% increased Hazard and that's not
just a statistic that's a warning the
study concluded that there could be
multiple reasons all of which are highly
concerning it could mean that
optometrists are not adequately trained
in the laser procedure itself it could
mean that optometrist do not understand
how to perform the gonioscopy which is a
tricky test to evaluate if the patient
is even a candidate for the surgery or
it could mean that optometrists don't
understand that you have to wait 6 to 8
weeks before you know if the laser
worked initially this study illustrates
a real concern for patient safety and it
shows that it is not coste effective to
have optometrist do surgery and to quote
the investigators of the study quote
Health policy makers should be cautious
about approving laser privileges for
optometrist practicing in other states
it's important important to consider how
professional malpractice companies view
optometrist performing surgery the
Opthalmic Mutual Insurance Company
ensures over 6,500 Opthomologist and
over 800 optometrist but they will not
provide malpractice insurance to
optometrist who perform surgery and they
say they won't citing a lack of
available data on liability and lack of
necessary education training and
experience in the handful of states that
have authorized optometrist to perform
surgery there are cases involving
surgical complications misdiagnosis and
harm patients some of whom have suffered
permanent vision loss those who were
here last year heard from Vicky rutage
and if you um haven't seen her testimony
I urge you to go back and view it these
procedures are not simple and
uncomplicated the patients harm during
procedures performed by optometrist in
Oklahoma Kentucky and Louisiana would
certainly attest to that they are real
people who experienced real harm my
opposition to House Bill 349 is firmly
rooted in patient safety and I hope that
you will also oppose this Bill thank you
for your time and I'm happy to answer
any
questions thank you are there
questions thank you the advantage of
coming late the questions have all
all right good afternoon everyone uh my
name is Grant uh Shai someone of the
Opthalmology residents at Dartmouth if
you have a specific question about
Opthalmology residency I can answer it
from firsthand experience um as
requested I won't sort of read my
remarks which are in sort of our written
packet I'll just try to summarize some
of the key highlights um one of the big
things that and I've learned going
through my residency program is it's um
one thing that's really important to
develop as a surge is not only the depth
of training in other words maybe how
many procedures you've done but the
breadth of training how many types of
procedures you've done um when I was uh
first learning to do these yag
capsulotomies that's one of the lasers
that are in this bill I honestly
struggled a lot it's hard to see that
posterior capsule it's very thin sort of
in the two to four Micron sort of
thickness if memory serves um I got
better at it though when my uh former PD
really took me into the operating room
to do cataract surgery you see the
capsule under a micro surgical
microscope you can see exactly what is
being targeted in the yag
capsulotomy um so you know it's been
testified earlier that in Opthalmology
residency you do lots of different types
of procedures many of which are not
related to the laser therapy but what I
would um propose is that it's actually a
feature of our training not a a bug to
do different types of surgery you get
better at surgery by doing different
types of surgery that's why the training
is what it
is um and what I feel is the hardest
part of being a Opthalmology resident is
not actually doing the technical aspects
of the procedure but actually knowing
the um that you're doing the right
procedure for that patient um it's not
something you can read in a book and
just say these are the clear indications
um it's not something you can get by
seeing maybe even a few uh patient
examples it honestly takes example after
example after example for years to know
um when patients would benefit from a
surgery it's really hard um and I think
that is sort of something that I feel
very fortunate to get in my Opthalmology
residency which is an important sort of
component of treating patients well um I
think optometrist have already um
testified as to their specific sort of
training uh for their procedures but
what I would feel like as I was going
through my residency is If I Only Had
specific training and sort of um laser
treatments you know in sort of models or
even on a few live patients I would not
feel comfortable doing even those
procedures because I don't feel like I
would have the depth or or excuse me the
breadth of surgical experience necessary
to know when to do those procedures
safely and um uh maybe uh not having as
best control of my hands that I got from
other types of procedures um there's the
big big things I wanted to say I would
like to say just lastly that you know
we're all in the same team and I hope
that even though I don't think this is
the right Bill policy for to advance New
Hampshire I hope that it can sort of
stimulate discussion to get us to a
better better place so thank you I'm
happy to answer any questions if there
are any thank you very much our
represent
scitec I can see your training as a
doctor is proceeding I can't read your
writing I worked a long time to write
Qui quickly as Ann h e h e i z um last
name is that what you're asking so s c u
l t h e i
s if you can say it three times that'd
be even better it's It's Tricky for all
of us thank you
yeah power thank you for taking my
question so I was just wondering how
many uh hours of training uh do you as a
resident do and will do uh throughout
your
residency thank you for the question um
I um have not keeping track on an hour
by- hour basis because I think it would
make me maybe a little uh remiss for
some of the hours that it could have
spent in other ways I think a rough
estimate is about
177,000 but um to give you a rough
perspective it changes year to year as a
resident in intern year I was logging
routinely around the 55 to 65 hours uh
Mark each week for that year when I was
doing a pgy2 year I was doing a little
bit less
maybe um average ballpark 55 hours a lot
of that was one week on call than one
week off call so you know I saw I've
seen patients with acute angle closure
which was one of the things that was
brought up earlier that needs an urgent
LPI I've seen exactly four I've tried
two lpis overnight I've gotten exactly
one to work and that's when I've had
I've done a few PR procedures by by that
point they're they're they're
tricky thank you other
questions thank you very much for your
Stratton good afternoon um thank you for
hearing my testimony today um I had a
longer statement but in the interest of
time I'm not going to repeat what others
have said but instead Spotlight their
testimony uh my name is Kathy Stratton
I'm the CEO of the New Hampshire Medical
Society and the medical society strongly
opposes House Bill 349 relative to the
practice of Optometry and authorization
to perform Opthalmic laser
procedures the medical society and
Physicians of New Hampshire value the
contributions of the entire clinical
team we're here not to detract from the
skill and contri Fusion of
optometrist but to ask you to uphold the
care the issues I want to Spotlight that
others have presented today is that um
these are serious medical surgeries that
house bill 49 will not expand access
that training and education matters uh
though current educational programs for
optometrists include training for this
procedure many practicing optometrists
in New Hampshire will not have that
level of
training um IE surgeons and
opthamologists are broadly trained and
uniquely qualified to identify and
respond to medical issues and address
any unexpected or adverse outcomes New
Hampshire's eye surgeons are actively
working on a plan to expand access in
the north
regions and I want to finish up by
saying that the human body is Cal
complex and the medical society urges
you to consider the benefit of this
broad medical education and clinical
training of
opthamologists it's likely the most
asked question when patients that qu
patients have When selecting a clinical
provider our state's eye physicians are
uniquely qualified to provide
highlevel health care and for these
reasons the New Hampshire Medical
Society encourages the committee to
passl thank you itl her language was
perfectly understandable are there any
questions yes representative SCH thank
you madam chair I was only correcting
her in terms of her terminology I
understood what she was saying anyway so
the thing is the the Medical Society has
taken a clear position here we've heard
from Dr Peters and a couple of others
to with regard to the proposed facility
at Anders
gaget can you make a commitment today to
us that the medical society will stand
behind these efforts to
expedite
those uh the the the ability to perform
those procedures for the residents of
the North country as quickly as possible
well
um I will qualify my response um that
you know this is an independent Endeavor
we are working with the um I the Society
of I
surgeons and to to move this along as
quickly as possible I mean we're we're
not in the driver's seat here but we are
supporting that endeavor and we do see
this as a model um for other uh you know
in for for other
Specialties that may need to expand care
in that way I'll bring this contract
over afterwards for your thank you very
and let me just say I've been with the
medical society five months so um I'm
happy to be here in New Hampshire and
working with Physicians toward uh
quality Care here representative scitec
has a question uh the chair uh
word of the day other
questions thank you very much thank you
all for your
mandoo thank you madam chairin to let me
speak today and members of the committee
my name is Katherine morando I'm an
opthalmologist physician and surgeon
here at ey Center in town and I'm also a
glaucoma
specialist I apologize I'm a little sick
today but I'm here today in strong
opposition to house spill 349 out of
concern for the safety of my patients I
think the testimonies so far have been
pretty good I know you've been here a
long time so I don't mean to reiterate
what's already been said my plan was to
talk about laser safety and um and the
exact details of the laser surgeries
being discussed in this bill and I have
some diagrams but um
if you feel you understand the lasers
being discussed in this bill I also
don't want to bore you to tears so um I
may just see if there's a general
consensus it doesn't look like there's
vast enthusiasm for more details than no
okay so if you feel you understand the
lasers there is a lot of detail in the
handout that was uh the packet that
large packet we gave and I have these
diagrams as well I'll stick around if
anyone has a burning interest in
Opthalmology or Opthalmic surgery and
wants to see the details but I don't
want to put you to sleep um either if
there are specific questions too I would
that are still burning I'd be happy to
just directly answer those um before
hitting the
highlights I think the highlights would
be the best okay so the highlights um
you know I think in just in general I
think there's a misguided comfort in
laser surgery thinking you just kind of
go into a room the doctor pushes a
button and that's that's all that
happens but it's a surgery a laser is a
tool used by a surgeon just like a
scalpel it burns it melts it coagulates
and Alters tissues and there are serious
blinding risks involved
um as far as the laser iridotomy goes um
you know I I don't want to bore you with
all that you said you think you know it
so I'll stick I guess with my part of it
as a glaucoma specialist after
completing four years of a surgical
training in Opthalmology I did an
additional year of glaucoma training in
glaucoma surgery and lasers and I get a
lot of even internal referrals from
other opthalmologists for these lasers
and these are other surgeons who
technically can do these surgeries but
they send them to me because the Nuance
of deciding who needs surgery can be
complicated um and some of these lasers
can be challenging especially these most
99.9% of the time these are not an
emergency the very rare time that the
iridotomy laser is an emergency is
really difficult when you're dealing
with these patients vomiting in front of
you their cornea is cloudy um you can't
even do the laser most of the time
because you can't see the tissue it's
too swollen you're giving them
medications and treating them and
sometimes you just need to take them
right to the operating room so um I
think most of the time these are
elective lasers and sometimes they can
get pretty
complicated um I did have one of my
mentors in in training taught me very
early on that knowing who to operate on
and when is just as important as knowing
how to perform the surgery and that is
really what's honed over five years of
surgical residency and fellowship under
the guidance of experienced surgeons and
these decisions don't just involve
knowing this these three surgeries but
also the scope of all other surgeries
that you do and and sometimes one is a
better option than the other I think
I've seen a lot of um incorrect
referrals as well that um do concern me
for consider I'm sending this patient
over to consider doing an SLT laser I've
recently had a patient sent to me with a
pressure of 40 that's very high and she
was taking every drop already um that we
have and there were refr was for that
glaucoma laser that would have been a
blinding decision for her because that
laser takes six weeks to work it would
not have worked well enough and that is
an early intervention I was really
grateful the patient came to me we got
her right into the operating room and I
just saw her for a year followup and
she's doing great but it just it wasn't
the right option for that patient so I
worry that if the referring provider had
done that then we would have just
delayed her access to care I would also
say that um I get a like hundreds per
year of referrals for that iridotomy of
those referrals I probably perform about
50% um that's because there's new
literature suggesting most of them can
be safely monitored or they're better
suited with earlier cataract surgery
instead um so I think it's a good thing
when we can not overperform procedures
it's good for the medical system and
good for patients to prevent them from
getting complications but um I worry
that if we expand Ed scope of some of
these procedures the overall rate of
procedures might increase and therefore
the rate of complications would
increase um again I'm happy to go over
the lasers later I think those are
really the highlights and like everyone
else has said I have lots of friends who
are optometrists I spoke to them before
coming here today to make sure that I
wasn't misunderstanding what we were
saying and they reiterated to me no I I
never did a laser ever in training
recent friends who graduated from
Massachusetts some of them are in states
where they legally can practice and they
said they get these emails saying sign
up for this weekend course to do a laser
and um they're sort of shocked by it as
are we so I hope we can keep working
together like we do every day to the
highest um abilities in our our
professions and keep taking care of the
patients of New
questions I'm happy to participate in a
subcommittee
okay thank you for that too and
um seeing no further questions thank you
again thank you is there anyone else who
349 all right seeing none I will close
the public hearing it will be going to
subcommittee and representative Pearson
s